SENATE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING IN THE BEARD SOCIAL
DISTANCING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS. TO THE
LAST LEGISLATIVE PROCESS TO
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INTO THE HEARING ROOM AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISAGREE
WIREMAN TO LOUD AND WE'RE USING
A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND ALL DOUBTS ABOUT
. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
ONE. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE THAT'S
EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE
FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. FOUR SIX SIX
THREE NINE SIX EIGHT. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS. ON THE
TELECONFERENCES TERM HAND HOW IT
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY THE MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION. PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO SIGN A NUMBER. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
CALL WAITING QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YEAR YOU
WILL BE A NEW UNIT IN YOUR NOW
READY TO ACT ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. FOR TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WILL BE
TAKE HEARING FROM OUR PANELISTS
LISTED ON THE AGENDA PRIOR TO
TAKING ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ONCE
WE HEAR FROM OUR PANELISTS WILL
HAVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON
TOPICS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. FOR A
BILL HEARING THE COMMITTEE WILL
OUT TO ME WITNESSES PER SIDE
WILL LIMIT EACH WITNESS TO TWO
MINUTES EACH. WE'LL BE KEEPING
TRACK OF THE TIME TO MAKE SO
MAKE SURE YOUR BRIEF ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE YOUR DEVICE. YOUR
WATCHING ON PRIOR TO THE YEAR.
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. LET ME REPEAT THAT
AGAIN BECAUSE WE HAD A NUMBER.
OF THIS- G. YESTERDAY ALONE- YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON. PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT WE HEAR
FROM YOU WE THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. ALL MAINTAIN QUORUM IS
- CUSTOMARY DURING THIS HEARING
IN ANY INDIVIDUALS DISRUPTIVE
WILL BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WE WILL BEGIN
WITH OUR INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON THE ONE YEAR CONTACT EACH-
EXTENSIONS FOLLOWED BY ARBIL
HEARING. SO FOR THOSE WHO DON'T
KNOW I'M SENATOR BILL DODD I'M
THE CHAIRMAN OF THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE TODAY WILL BE HOLDING
AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THE
WHEN YOU'RE CONTACTING
STANCHIONS BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN THE CAPITAL
BEYOND THE MIDDLE TEN RANCHERIA
THE SANTA ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY
AND TABLE MOUNTAIN RANCHERIA.
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE
UNFAMILIAR WITH THE SENATE
PROCEDURE THE ESTABLISHED POLICY
ALLOWS FOR THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING ON THE DETAILS OF THE
CAN'T COMPACT TO BE FOLLOWED BY
A VOTE ON THE SENATE FLOOR. NO
VOTE WILL BE TAKEN HERE TODAY.
THE VEHICLE FOR RATIFICATION FOR
THIS COMPACT EXTENSION WILL BE
S. B. EIGHT NINETY EIGHT BY
YOURS TRULY. I BELIEVE MR OF
O'KELLY- TRIBAL NEGOTIATOR FOR
THE GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS HERE IN
THE CHAMBER MISTER MCNALLY
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BE YET. THE
MORNING THANK YOU CHAIRMAN DON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. J. THE CHANCE
THIS MORNING TO CRIED RIGHT
INFORMATION ON THE CONTACT
AMENDMENTS IN FRONT OF THE
SENATE GEO COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
NATHAN VOCALLY ON THE SENIOR
ADVISER FOR TRAVEL NEGOTIATIONS
FOR THE OFFICE. BEFORE WE START
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE TRIBES
IN THEIR CHAIRPERSONS CHAIR
MARKETS QUERO CAMPER VAN TO DIG
WHEN YOU MISSION INDIANS JOSE
SIMON THE THIRD FOR MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA CHADLI A CISCO FOR
SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA AND CHAIR
BRENDA LOVELL FOR TABLE MOUNTAIN
RANCHERIA. THESE FOUR TRIBES ARE
ALL CURRENTLY CONDUCTING CLASS
THREE GAMING PURSUANT TO TRIBAL
STATE GAMING COMPACT ORIGINALLY
SIGNED IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
ANDREFERRED TO AS NINETY NINE
CONTACT. SB EIGHT NINETY EIGHT
WOULD RATIFY AMENDMENTS
EXTENDING THESE NINETY NINE
CONTACTS FOR ONE YEAR TO JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
I'LL GIVE A VERY BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON THE NINETY NINE
CONTACTS TOUCH ON THE RASON FOR
THE EXTENSIONS AND THEN WRAP UP
WITH THE PROCESS FOR FINALIZING
THOSE EXTENSIONS. IN TWO
THOUSAND PROP ONE A. GRANTED
TRIBES THE EXCLUSIVE RIGHT TO
OPERATE SLOT MACHINES AND
BANKING IN PERCENTAGE CARD GAMES
IN CALIFORNIA. PROP ANDONE A
WAS CODIFIED IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION ARTICLE FOUR
SECTION NINETEEN WHICH ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE GOVERNOR TO
NEGOTIATE. COMPAQ'S INCLUDING
AMENDMENTS SUBJECT TO
LEGISLATIVE RATIFICATION. IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE TO TWO
THOUSAND THE STATE ENTERED INTO
OVER SIXTY TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACTS PURSUANT TO THE INDIAN
GAMING REGULATORY ACT. THE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE CONTACTS
WERE FOR AN INITIAL TWENTY YEAR
TERM EXPIRING DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. THE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE CONTACTS
ARE AUTOMATICALLY EXTENDED FOR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS FOR TRYING THAT
DID NOT YET HAVE A NEW CONTACT.
THOSE NINETY NINETY NINE
CONTACTS NOW EXPIRE BY THEIR OWN
TERMS ON JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE NINETEEN NINETY
NINE CONTACTS ALLOWED BUT DO NOT
REQUIRE SURE I'VE IN THE STATE
TO EXTEND THEIR TERM BY MUTUAL
AGREEMENT. MORE RECENTLY IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE EIGHT TRIBES
WITH NINETEEN NINETY NINE
CONTACTS SIGNS NEW CONTACTS.
THREE OF THESE CONTACTS
INCLUDING THOSE FOR MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA AND SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA WERE RATIFIED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND SUBMITTED TO THE
SECRETARY FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR FOR REQUIRED FORTY FIVE
DAY REVIEW. UNDER THE INDIAN
GAMING REGULATORY ACT. THE
PRIMARY REASON FOR THESE
EXTENSIONS IS THAT IN NOVEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE ASSISTANT
SECRETARY FOR INDIAN AFFAIRS.
PURSUANT TO AUTHORITY DELEGATED
FROM THE SECRETARY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR
DISAPPROVE THREE OF THE GAMING
COMPACTS. AS A RESULT OF THOSE
CONTACT US APPROVALS IT BECAME
CLEAR THAT THE STATE AND
REMAINING NINETEEN NINETY NINE
CONTACT CRIMES. WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO NEGOTIATE A NEW COMPACT
WITH SUFFICIENT CONFIDENCE THAT
THE NEW CONTACTS WOULD TAKE
EFFECT UNDER A GRAD. BEFORE
TRIES NINETY NINE CONTACT
EXPIRES ON JUNE THIRTIETH OF
THIS YEAR. A ONE YEAR EXTENSION
SHOULD AFFORD SUFFICIENT TIME TO
HELP ADDRESS THE UNCERTAINTY
CREATED BY THE RECENT CONTACT IS
APPROVALS. AND ALLOW THE STATE
TO NEGOTIATE NEW CONTACTS WITH
TRIBES THAT ARE INTERESTED IN
DOING SO. THESE FOUR TRIBES HAVE
ALL AGREED TO ONE YEAR
EXTENSIONS FOR THEIR NINETEEN
NINETY NINE CONTACTS. OTHER
TRIBES HAVE PUBLICLY EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN A LONGER TERM
EXTENSION. THE EXTENSION IS
EFFECTIVELY AN AMENDMENT TO THE
CONTACT FOR PURPOSES OF STATE
LAW. THE AMENDMENTS WERE
NEGOTIATED BY THE GOVERNOR AND
MUST BE RATIFIED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. AND
AMENDMENTS ONLY TO EXTEND THE
TERM OF THE CONTACT UNDER
FEDERAL LAW DOES NOT REQUIRE.
THE SECRETARY OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF INTERIOR TO APPROVE THE
EXTENSION BUT IT STILL MUST BE
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT.
THESE AMENDMENTS TO EXTEND THE
CONTACTS FOR ONE YEAR WOULD NOT
PREVENT THE STATE TRIBES FOR
MUTUALLY AGREEING TO FURTHER
EXTENSIONS AS NECESSARY. I
APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S TIME TODAY
AND I REMAIN AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VOCALOID APOLOGIES FOR
MISPRONOUNCING YOUR NAME OUT AT
THE TOP. THAT'S NOT A PROBLEM I
GET IT ALL IN ALL DIFFERENT
KINDS OF WAYS THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE IT BEFORE WE MOVED
QUESTIONS- IN COMMENTS BY
MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
THE PUBLIC WANTED TO PARTICIPATE
THE CALLING NOW AS A REMINDER
PLEASE DIAL THIS TOLL FREE
NUMBER. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE
ONE AND A FOUR ONE EIGHT FIVE
WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE THE
ACCESS CODE FOUR SIX SIX THREE
NINE. SIX EIGHT WILL NOW BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS- MANY MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE WAS
QUITE CLEAR AND CONCISE. FOR
MISTER MOBILITY- YOU KNOW I DO
HAVE ONE HERE- A MISTER VOCALLY-
THERE'S BEEN SOME CONCERN BY A
NUMBER OF THE NINETEEN NINETY
TRIBES YOU BREAK OUT OF-
MENTIONED IT DID A YEAR MAY NOT
BE ENOUGH TO FINALIZE A COMPACT
CAN YOU JUST KIND OF COMMENT ON
THAT JUST SO THAT MEMBERS HAVE-
SOME IDEA EXCEPT SURE THEY'VE
HEARD ABOUT THIS. THE COULD YOU
SAY THAT ONE MORE TIME I HEARD
THAT YEAH THERE'S BEEN CONCERNED
ABOUT A NUMBER BY A NUMBER OF
TRIBES IN ONE YEAR MAY NOT BE
ENOUGH OBVIOUSLY THE TRIBES HERE
TODAY ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
THEY THINK THAT THEY CAN DO THIS
BUT THERE'S OTHERS AND I KNOW
THE MEMBERS OF HEARD THIS AND-
CAN YOU COMMENT ON WHY YOU THINK
A YEAR IS. AB- IS- ACCEPTABLE OR
OR WHAT IN WHAT'S GOING ON HERE
IN YOUR MIND YEAH CERTAINLY SO
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
ESSENTIALLY RESET THE CLOCK BACK
TO NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND WHEN WE HAVE THOSE JUST
APPROVALS FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INTERIOR FOR THE THREE CONTACTS
WE THINK WE'RE ON TRACK TO HAVE
A PROCESS TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH NEW CONTACTS- WELL
AHEAD OF NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
TWO SO WE THINK WE'RE IN GOOD
SHAPE TO GET BACK ON TO THE-
THAT ONE YEAR DELAY BUT TO GET
US BACK TO JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY THREE FOR THE- FOR THE
NINETEEN NINETY NINE CONTACTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT'S
HELPFUL. BUT IT APPEARS- AT
LEAST THAT'S ACCORDING TO- MY
AGENDA THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO
THE PUBLIC- DISCUSSION FIRST AND
THEN WILL ASK MEMBERS- OF THE-
PRINCIPLES OF THE PARTIES TO-
TOOK TO COMMENT SO- WILL NOW
MOVE ON ANYONE WANT TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT- IT'S A REMINDER
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS ON LAKES THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS. MAY INITIATE
TIMES LIMITS I ASKED THOSE
SEEKING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY TO
UNDER A MINUTE NOT REPEAT THE
POINTS. YOU KNOW WHAT I HAVE I
APOLOGISE FOR MY ORIGINAL
COMMENTS I THINK I'M JUST READ
THE SCRIPT HERE SO WE ARE GOING
TO START I BELIEVE CHAIRMAN'S
SYLVIA OF. THE NAGA AND VICE
CHAIRMAN- OF MORONGO ON THE
COASTLINE TO PROVIDE SOME
COMMENTS. YES THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
DONE. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN DIED
IN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING THE TIME
TO SPEAK THIS MORNING. WE ARE
HERE TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT.
FOR SB EIGHT NINE EIGHT. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE UNITED
SUPREMO COURT. RECOGNIZE
INHERENT SOVEREIGN RIGHT TO
TRIED TO HAVE GAME ON THEIR
LAND. UNITED IS THE MAGAZINE
DEDICATED TO THE PROTECTION OF
THE UNIT HERE IN RIGHT IN THE
GOVERNMENT THE GOVERNMENT
NEGOTIATION OF TRIBAL STATE
COMPACT. EITHER THAT OR
RESPECTFUL OF UNIQUE TO CONTENT
OF THE TRIBE. SB EIGHT NINE
EIGHT CERTAINLY REFLECT THE
SENATE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
DECISION OF THESE FOR TRIED.
THREE WHICH ARE CAN I GET
MEMBERS. IT TAKES A YEAR LINE
EXPANSION OF THEIR CURRENT
CONTRACT TERMS. WE HAVE FOR YES
VOTE ON THE LEGISLATION. WHAT WE
AGAIN THE PORT THE RITE OF
TRIBES DECIDE WHAT IS BEST FOR
THEMSELVES. THEY MIGHT BE
KNOWLEDGE THE TRIBES HAVE
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES AND
DIFFERENT NEED. THERE SHOULD
NEVER BE A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
COOKIE CUTTER APPROACH TO TRIBAL
AGREEMENT. AND THAT WE SUPPORT
THE RIGHT OF TRIED TO TAKE THE
ONE YEAR EXTENSION OFFERED. WE
ALSO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE
SEVERAL OTHER TRIES INCLUDING
THE NUMBER OF THE MEGA MEMBER
TRIBE. THAT PHILIP THIRTY MONTH
EXTENSION WOULD BE MUCH BETTER
FIT FOR THEIR UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES. FOREMOST AMONG
THE FACTORS ARE MULTIPLE FEDERAL
COURT CASES THAT HAVE YET TO BE
RESOLVED. INCLUDING THE STATE ON
APPEAL AND CHICKEN RANCH
RANCHERIA THE NEWS THEM. IN THAT
CASE THE FEDERAL DISTRICT COURT
IN FRESNO FOUND AT THE STATE AND
NOT NEGOTIATED IN GOOD FAITH
WITH FIVE TRIED. TO THE STATE
INSISTENCE ON INCLUDING
CERTAINLY CONTACT PROVISION.
WHICH THE TRIBES HAD OBJECTED
INCONSISTENT WITH AGRA. THAT
CASE IS NOW PENDING BEFORE THE
NINTH CIRCUIT. THE DIFFERENT
CORNER FRESNO NOW HAS EIGHT
OTHER CASES PENDING IN VERY
SIMILAR ISSUE. PUBLIC RADIO
MATTERS FURTHER. EVEN TRIED TO
AGREE TO THE STATE CERTAIN TODAY
THE DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR WHICH
MUST ALSO REVIEW THE COMPACT
WOULD ALMOST CERTAINLY
DISAPPROVE THEM FOR INCLUDING
PROVISIONS DEEMED OUT OF THE
SCOPE OF EGRA AND THEY RECENTLY
DID THE LAST FOUR RATIFIED
COMPAQ. AT THIS POINT EVEN IF
THE CASE WERE TO BE RESOLVED.
NEGOTIATING RATIFYING AND
OBTAINING THE L. I APPROVAL
THIRTY NEW COMPACT. COULD NOT BE
COMPLETED BY JUNE THIRTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THEREFORE WE
URGE YOU TO ENCOURAGE THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS NEGOTIATORS PUT
FORWARD CONTACT EXTENSION THAT A
REALISTIC THE UNIQUE ENVIRONMENT
IT IS TROUBLE GOVERNMENT. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TIME TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. AND AGAIN
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT SB EIGHT
NINE EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT- NOW
LET'S MOVE ON TO- THE GALLERY-
ANYBODY HERE THAT WANTS TO
PROVIDE US A COMMENT. PLEASE
COME FOR. WE DO HAVE SOME
SPEAKERS. THE MORNING GERMAN THE
SENATE COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS LEO
CISCO IN THE CENTER WAS A
RANCHERIA TOUCHY OKAY TRIBAL
CHAIRMAN. AND WE'RE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT NINETY
EIGHT. AND CENTER WAS OUR TRIP A
ONE YEAR EXTENSION WILL-
COMPLETE THE HELP US COMPLETE
THE RATIFICATION OF OUR CONTACT
. THANK YOU CHAIRMAN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH XP- GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING- MY NAME'S MICHELLE PENA
I'M AN ATTORNEY FOR MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE TRIBE IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT NINETY EIGHT AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MORNING
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FRANK MOLINA ON BEHALF
OF THE SALMON WILL BID TO
MISSION INDIANS IN THE SENATE IS
MANAGED THROUGH MASS INDIANS. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THESE
EXCEPTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISS MOLINA. ANYBODY- IN THE
GALLERY SIR PLEASE SEE GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN DIED MEMBERS
MARIO HE DID HE ON BEHALF OF
UNITE HERE THE CASINO WORKERS
UNION IN NORTH AMERICA. MORNING
TO THE CHAIRMAN PRESIDENT
MEMBERS OF THE TRIBES. WE'RE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
NINE EIGHT AND WE ALSO. SHOULD
SAY THAT- FOR. THREE SETS OF
REASONS- THE CONCERNS AROUND THE
SYCUAN CASINO RESORTS- DISREGARD
FOR THEIR TRAVEL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE- THE SUITS ACTUALLY
MENTION IN PUBLIC COMMENT-
DROPPED BY A NUMBER OF TRIBES
AGAINST THE APPROPRIATENESS OF-
THE TAYLOR ROSE THE SUBJECT OF
COMPACT NEGOTIATIONS. AND ALSO
WE SHOULD MENTION ON THE RECENT
NEAR SUCCESSFUL ATTEMPTS THREE
IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS- TO. MAKE
THE NLRA THE NATIONAL LABOR
RELATIONS ACT NO LONGER
APPLICABLE TO TRAVEL GAMING.
FACILITIES WE URGE NO MORE THAN
ONE YEAR EXTENSIONS- GOING
FORWARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE GALLERY. C. NINE. I
WILL NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND FEEL FREE TO
OPEN THE LINES- IN. WE CAN CALL
YOU A MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INDIVIDUALLY. THANK YOU LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD BUT YES ONE
ZERO. WE DO HAVE A NUMBER HERE
DECIDE GIVE US A MOMENT HERE
ASTRAEA IDENTICAL A LINE NUMBER
. AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO.
AND WE CAN GO AHEAD OPEN LINE
THIRTY FOUR. PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIRTY FOUR. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THE APPLE. MICROCLINE COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
THE HOUSE IT WILL NOT MANCHURIA
AND STRONG SUPPORTER THIS ONE
YOUR MEASURE THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE CAN LIKE GO TO LINE TWELVE IS
GO AHEAD. MORNING EVERYONE THIS
IS CHANGING FERRUM THE VICE
CHAIRPERSON FOR MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. AND CURRENTLY NINE
FURTHER IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU
HAVING HEARD ALL THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WHICH FAKE- MISTER
VOCALLY FIRST TESTIMONY
CONTINUED WORK ON THESE CONTACTS
NOW THAT WE'RE DONE WITH THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR BILL HEARING I WANT TO
THANK. EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TENANTS PROCEEDED.
OKAY WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON OUR
AGENDA TODAY HOWEVER FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR. THEY HAVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER- TWENTY FIVE SB CHANNEL
FOR. IS THAT A POLL. THAT'S BEEN
PULLED AS WELL. SO BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATION ON THE BILLS
DO WE HAVE A QUORUM. AS THE
SECTOR. IS THAT A YES OKAY CAN
WE- CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. BOB
DOT HERE DOT HERE NIELSEN. ALLEN
ALLEN HERE ARCHULETA. ARTS WHAT
I HEAR BAKER. BAKER HERE
GORGEOUS BORDERS HERE BRADFORD
GLAZER WESO JONES KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ HERE
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO HERE
RUBIO. RUBIO PRESENT WILK WE
HAVE A QUORUM OKAY WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL BEGIN WITH OUR
CONSECUTIVE WHICH INCLUDES ONLY
ONE ITEM- FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
S. B. NINE- TWENTY SIX MAY I
HAVE A MOTION. MOTION BY SENATOR
ARCH ALETTA IN THE DISCUSSION.
YOU'VE HE'S PROCEED WITH THE
VOTE- THIS IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DODD HI DOT HI NIELSEN
ALLEN. ALLEN HI ARE TO ADAM
ARCHULETA HI BAKER. BAKER I
BORDERS BORDERS AYE BRADFORD
GLAZER WESO JONES KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE PORTANTINO
. PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO RUBIO AYE
WILK SHERMAN HAS EIGHT ON CALL
EIGHT VOTES WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL- APPARENTLY- SENATOR HER
SHE'S SHE'S HERE SHE'S NOT HERE
OKAY WE HAVE SOMEBODY IS SHE
HERE. WELL.
WHERE IS.
FILE ITEM THE CENTER BACK
THIRTEEN SURE HERE DO YOU WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PROCEED WITH YOUR
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB TWELVE
OH THREE. I TO GET MY BINDER.
VERY GOOD THIS BILL THAT I HAVE YEAH WHAT DID YOU START
WITH THAT WILL DO- SB TWELVE
FIFTY ONE- CENTER GONZALEZ IS
NOT FEELING WELL TODAY SO-
CENTER BACKER WILL BE PRESENTING
FOR HER. THANK YOU SENATOR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF SENATORS ALSO
PERCENT SENATE BILL TWELVE FIFTY
ONE WHICH WILL QUIT IS YOUR
MISSION EQUITY ADVOCATE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE YOUR MISSION
VEHICLES INCLUDING A PASSENGER
VEHICLES BUSES AND TRUCKS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO REDUCE OUR STATE'S
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND AIR
POLLUTION THAT HARMS SO MANY
CALIFORNIANS OVER ACCESS TO YOUR
MACHINE VEHICLES IS CURRENTLY
NOT EQUITABLE IN CALIFORNIA.
WHITE HIGHER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
ARE FAR MORE LIKELY TO OWN YOUR
MISSION VEHICLES ON LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS OF COLOR IRONICALLY
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE
EMISSIONS OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THE MOST
NEED OF YOUR MISSION VEHICLES
STATE AGENCIES HAVE TAKEN STEPS
TO ADDRESS. ACCESS INEQUALITY
INEQUITIES ORION IS YOUR MISSION
VEHICLES BUT THE DECENTRALIZED
pDIFFERENCE IS AN AGENCY SPECIFIC
GOALS HAVE LED TO INEFFICIENT.
THEY HAVE EQUITY INVESTMENTS.
THIS BILL SB TWELVE FIFTY ONE
WILL TACKLE THIS ISSUE BY
CREATING A ZERO EMISSION EQUITY
ADVOCATE. THAT WILL SERVE AS A
CENTRALIZED ENTRY QUEUE UP TO
PUT EQUITY FRONT AND CENTER IN
THE STATE'S. ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT PLAN. DESERVE
EQUITY ADVOCATE WILL ALSO.
PROVIDE A CENTRALIZED LOCATION
AT THE STATE FOR TREATING GAUGE
MEANT. AND WILL WORK TO ALIGN
EQUITY DEFINITIONS GOALS AND
INVESTMENTS ACROSS THE STATE
AGENCIES. SB TWELVE THIRTY ONE
WHICH IS THE CURRENT GAPS IN
EQUITY BY ENSURING LOCAL VOICES
ARE HEARD IN STATE PLANNING. AND
THAT THE EQUITY EFFORTS ACROSS
AGENCIES ARE LINED TO ENSURE
THAT YOUR MISSION VEHICLES ARE
ACCEPTABLE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS.
BUT TESTING. TEST RUNS FOR THE
BILL TODAY WE HAVE THE CEO OF
THE LOS ANGELES CLEANTECH
INCUBATOR. AND THE WESTERN
STATES PROGRAM MANAGER FOR EASY
HYBRID MARC. THANK YOU
ESPECIALLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON
SB TWELVE FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR- I'M NOT SURE IF THE-
DON'T FROM TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT- UNDERSTOOD THAT THIS
BILL WAS GOING TO COME UP SO
QUICKLY- MODERATORS OR ANYBODY
ON THE LINE. AND GIVE THEM A
MOMENT- IF YOU'LL PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME OF
MODERATE I'M SORRY- WE HAVE THE-
MAIN WITNESSES- YOU SAID THERE
ON THE LINE. OKAY FANTASTIC I
THINK IT'S EITHER MISTER
PETERSON OR MISS MORELAND-
PLEASE PROCEED. IN THE ORDER
THAT YOU HAD A DESIGNATED. THIS
IS MATT PETERSON GETTING HERE
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE SURE CAN'T
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
ONLINE AND BEING ON. AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE. WELL YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT WILL HAPPEN THANK YOU TO
YOUR DODD THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER- THANK YOU MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE STAFF- WANT TO THANK
SENATOR GONZALEZ FOR HER
LEADERSHIP. AND WORKING HAND IN
GLOVE WITH THE NORMAL JUSTICE-
AND COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AS WELL AS
ORGANIZATION LACY- DEVELOPED
THIS- S. B. THIS BILL SB TWELVE
FIFTY ONE- CENTER BECKER POINTED
OUT THE STATE WORKS TO ACHIEVE
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT. GOALS
TO TRANSITION CARS AND TRUCKS
AND BUSES THAT THEIR MISSIONS TO
REDUCE LIFE. THREATENING AND
THE- COMMUNITY DISRUPTING AIR
POLLUTION AND CLIMATE POLLUTION
WE NEED TO ENSURE WE HAVE
PRIORITIZE EQUITY WHERE WE CAN
IN THE STATE INVEST BILLIONS TO
SUPPORT THIS TRANSITION AS WELL
AS NOW OF COURSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- IS A CENTRAL- WE-
SAID AN EQUITY JENNIFER THE
DEPLOYMENT OF. YOUR MACHINE
VEHICLES SUPPORTING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT OF COURSE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT INCOME FROM
IT AS WELL- IN THE STAGE IN TURN
TURN TURN TREMENDOUS JOB
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION-
RESOURCES BOARD- OTHER IF YOU
SEE OTHER AGENCY. AND YET. THE
COURSE LOW GOVERNMENT YOU KILL
AND ALSO A GREAT. YEAH NEED TO
DO MY- TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
DOING. A DEPEND OF THE GERMAN
STRESSED FUTURE EVERY COMMUNITY
MEMBER- FAMILY- WE KNOW THAT
LACK OF ACCESS TO A CAR- WERE
INADEQUATE TRANSIT WORKER ALONG
WITH. THE DISPROPORTIONATE
BURDEN OF AIR POLLUTION JUST
ADDS TO IT BUT CHALLENGES- THAT
THESE COMMUNITIES FACE EVERY DAY
AND THAT TO TOUGH CHOICES BUT
FAMILY HAVE TO MAKE EVERY DAY-
SO- THAT'S WHY. THE SENATOR-
GONZALEZ IS INTRODUCED SB TWELVE
THIRTY ONE WHICH WOULD CREATE
THE OFFICE OF THE GERMAN BEER-
THE ICAL EQUITY ADVOCATE. IN THE
GOAL IS TO FACILITATE CONNECTION
BETWEEN COMMUNITY GROUPS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. UTILITIES AND
AGENCIES REGARDING. THAT EQUITY-
PROVIDING SERVICE SINGLE POINT
OF CONTACT HI TO BETTER ALIGN
EQUITY DEFINITIONS AND ENDING IN
METRICS ACROSS AGENCIES AND
PROGRAMS IN THE NIGHT OF FUNDING
EQUITY PARTICIPATION ACROSS
AGENCIES AND THERE'S AT THE
POINT WORK. I'M BAKER BERMAN THE
NEW FUNDING STREAMS AND PROGRAMS
TO PROMOTE AN EQUITABLE- THAT
DEPLOYMENT ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE U. S. STATE
PROGRAMS AND FUNDING FOR
EQUITABLE THAT DEPLOYMENT
PROVIDING REGULAR DATA REPORTS
AND HOW ALL THE STATUS OF
CHEATING EQUITABLE THAT
DEPLOYMENT. L. AND RELATED
OPPORTUNITIES TO ENHANCE AND
IMPROVE THE ALREADY STRONG.
PROGRAMS I. ACCESS IS OUR
MISSION CARS. AND BUSES IN THE
COMMUNITY TRANSIT OF COURSE AND
ALSO MOVE. THE COULD NOT BE A
NEED TO AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS TO
MACHINE AS WELL. A EXAMPLE OF-
I. FOR US PROGRAM THAT COULD BE
A APARTHEID'S ACT. THE AGE THAT.
FOR MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY COMMERCIAL
VEHICLES- OUR FIRST FIRST SERVE
- REGULATIONS WITHIN SECONDS IN
FACT INSIDE WE HOW DO WE REFINE
THOSE TO US FOR PETERSON YOU'RE
ON YOUR WAY OR WHATEVER TIME YOU
NEED TO WRAP IT UP CERVANTES.
THERE ARE. LIKE THAT MY PHONE
COMES IS THE THIS WOULD BE ONE
UPPER. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
YEAH YOUR TEST THANK YOU FOR
HERE AND- AND- BEING SO FLEXIBLE
IS MRS MORE MISS MORELAND ON THE
LINE. YES I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES PLEASE PROCEED. WONDERFUL
THANK YOU MATT THE LADY TEAM AND
SENATORS AND DOLLARS FOR WORKING
WITH MY ORGANIZATION AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATE
ACROSS THE STATE TO DEVELOP AT
THE TWELVE THIRTY ONE AND THANK
YOU CHAIR DOTTING COMMITTEE
STAFF. I DON'T THINK THE PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR EATING A ARE IN THE
HARBOR NORTH OUR NATIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS ARE COMMITTED TO
ENDING RACIAL DISPARITIES IN
ACCESS TO CLEAN ELECTRIC
VEHICLES WILL BE IN JOB
CREATION. I'M HERE TODAY TO URGE
YOU TO SUPPORT SB TWELVE FIFTY
ONE BUT TO CREATE A ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE OR THEN EQUITY
ADVOCATE WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. A CALIFORNIA MOVES
TOWARD ITS EMISSIONS LEVELS WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR ENSURING WE ARE ALSO
ADVANCING AT THE WILL POLICIES.
CALIFORNIA IS THE WORLD LEADER
IN THE MARKET HOWEVER OUR LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS AND HELP WITH
THE COLOR ARE FAR LESS LIKELY TO
OWN THEM. IN WHITE HIGHER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. PRIOR TO MY CURRENT
LAW I HAD OPPORTUNITY TO. CHEN
ALLEGE. DIRECT THROUGH THE- AREA
CLING FOR ALL PROGRAMS. WHICH
ALSO A FIRST FIRST PROGRAM. I
THE NEED HAVE A- ADVOCATE TO
ENSURE OUR PLANNING INCLUDING.
IN EQUITY. AND LEAVES THE LONG
TERM OUR WORK. THAT CAN BENEFIT
THE MOST A LOT. I THINK TWELVE
FIFTY WANT TO ADDRESS THE
CURRENT IN EQUITY IN THAT
DEPLOYMENT. BY CREATING OFFICE
AND THEN EQUITY ADVOCATE. IN
ADDITION TO WHAT NOT SHARING THE
OFFICE WILL PROVIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATES
LIKE MYSELF. WITH A SINGLE
ENTITY TO HOLD ACCOUNTABLE FOR
ENSURING ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
IS PRIORITIZED IN THE
TRANSITION. MAKE IT MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ADVOCATE.
HE'S TRACKING INFLUENCE MORE
THAN TWENTY AGENCIES THAT
POLICIES MATTER AND PROVIDE AN
INDEPENDENT VOICE TO EVALUATE
CALIFORNIA PROGRESS. ACTUALLY
ACHIEVING THE STATE DOUBLE.
ONE SURE THAT THE STATE IS
MOVING TOWARDS EFFECTIVE.
COMMUNITY CENTER THAT EQUITY
POLICY IN THE MOST EFFICIENT AND
TRANSPARENT MANNER POSSIBLE.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY. OR HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S MOVE TO- IS EVERY ELSE IN
THE CHAMBER TO TESTIFY ON THIS.
ISSUE SEEING NINE LET'S MOVE TO
THE WITNESSES WAITED JUST FIVE
YOU THE TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE FIFTY ONE PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES OF CALL SUPPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY. AND WE WILL
CONTINUE. THANK YOU AND TO OFFER
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO.
AND CURRENTLY NOT IN Q. K. WITH
NONE IN Q. ARE. LET'S OPEN UP-
WILL FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
MODERATOR HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION. I THANK YOU AGAIN
IT'S ONE ZERO. FOUR OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
AGAIN NO- OUT NOBODY TO AT THIS
TIME OKAY THANK YOU- FOR THAT
MODERATOR WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO- THE MEMBERS.
THERE ANY DISCUSSIONS- SENATOR
RUBIO. CENTER RUBIO THREE CHAIR
SORRY ABOUT THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND I KNOW SHE'S SHE'S
NOT HERE TODAY SHE'S NOT FEELING
WELL BUT I THINK THIS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO OUR
SHE'S TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN THIS
BILL AND AS WE MOVE TOWARDS ARE
VERY AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
TAKE A STEP BACK AND BRING THOSE
COMMUNITIES ALONG THAT YOU KNOW
THAT I'VE BEEN SPEAKING ABOUT
FOR AWHILE NOW. I KNOW THERE
WERE VERY FOCUSED ON ON HAVING
THESE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES BY
WHEN WE THINK OF OUR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARY FIRST
THINKING ABOUT THAT I WANT TO
DRIVE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
THEY'RE THINKING DO I HAVE
TRANSPORTATION AT ALL SO THEY'RE
JUST FOCUSED ON TRANSPORTATION
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT TYPE OF
TRANSPORTATION IT IS AND IT HAS
BEEN MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THAT
A LOT OF THE TIMES THEY ARE TOLD
WHAT THE SHOULD BE DRIVING BUT
NOT NECESSARILY BRINGING THEM
ALONG IN TERMS OF EDUCATION AND
REALLY. AREN'T YOU KNOW PUT A
LAYING OUT WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT
THAT WE GET THERE AND SO I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO SEE THAT SHE'S
MOVING FOR WITH THIS BILL
SPECIALLY ARE OUR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES REALLY THEY'RE JUST
THINKING ABOUT MORE PRESSING
ISSUES LIKE HOUSING FOOD HOW TO
EDUCATE THEIR KIDS AND I THINK
THAT BRINGING THEM ALONG
GRADUALLY EDUCATING THEM I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT SO HAVING THE
CENTRALIZED OFFICE. THE FOCUS ON
SOME OF THESE EFFORTS ARE AGAIN
BRINGING THESE PORTABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE TYPICALLY
HAS THE TIME BECAUSE AGAIN MY
EXPEIENCE HAS ALWAYS TOLD WHAT
TO DRIVE BUT NOT Y. AND SOUL I
WANTTO COMMEND THE AUTHOR AND I
ALSO WANT TO- NOT ONLY MOVE THE
BILL BUT ALSO BE A JOINT AUTUMN
SORRY AT ISN'T CO AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL- BUT WE NEED TO BE
INCLUSIVE WE TAKE THEIR ISSUES
INTO CONSIDERATION AND WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THAT IT'S NOT EASY
FOR THEM WHEN THEY'RE STRUGGLING
WITH BASIC NEEDS TO WANT TO
INVEST IN A VEHICLE THAT THEY
CAN'T AFFORD AND SELL WITH THAT
CHERYL MOVED THE BILL AND AGAIN
ALSO LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO ADDRESS THAT'S
ARCHULETA. YES THANK YOU MISS.
AN FORD- SPONSOR ARE LEFT ON THE
AIR. ADDITIONAL I'M SURE THEY
ARE OKAY- GET AYE THIS IS GREAT
BILL AND MY COLLEAGUE EXPRESS
PERFECTLY JUST A MINUTE AGO BUT
I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT ALL
ASPECTS OF ENERGY IS INCLUDED IN
THE FUTURE. BECAUSE WE NEED TO
GIVE OPTIONS TO EVERYONE AND
THAT BRINGS UP- SOMETHING THAT
I'M PROMOTING ALL THE TIME- FUEL
CELL HYDROGEN AND- ALL OTHER
ASPECTS IS THAT. IN THE FUTURE-
OF THE BUILD WHAT WHAT UP WHAT'S
IT LOOK LIKE TO INCLUDE
EVERYTHING BECAUSE IT'S THE SAME
GOAL CLEAN AIR ENVIRONMENT ZERO
EMISSIONS BUT WE'VE GOT INCLUDE
EVERYTHING. COMMENT FROM THE
SPONSOR. A SPONSORED AD- WITNESS
IS STILL ON THE LINE. YES WE'RE
ON- IT WILL TO DISCUSS THAT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MATT
PETERSON REPLACING YEAH WE
GOTTEN CENTER ARE TO AS WE
DISCUSS THE LAST YEAR I THINK OF
THE AUTHOR AUTHOR- IN TALKING TO
HER STAFF- OPEN TO- MAKING SURE
THAT IT'S INCLUSIVE AND THAT'S
WHY WE'VE ALREADY DESCRIBED IT
AS A ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE NOT
JUST THE- ELECTRIC VEHICLE
UNPLUG THE BATTERY. ELECTRIC
VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY ONLY. BREGGEN
MATURE THANK YOU. OKAY THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
RUBIO- THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE- YOU
HAVE A CLOSER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
DO FOR US CENTER GONZALEZ WHAT
YOU THINK MY COLLEAGUES AND FOR
THE REMARKS AND I WANTED IT IS
ECHO WHAT CENTER RUBIO SAID I
THINK THAT- HAS BEEN SEVERAL
YEARS NOW SINCE THEN CENTER DALY
ON SEP TACKLE A MILLION ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND IT HAS NOT BEEN
EACH EQUALLY DISTRIBUTED AND THE
EXPERIENCE. OF MAJORITY OF OUR
STATE SPECIALLY LOCUM
CALIFORNIANS OF THIS TRANSITION
CAN'T JUST BE SIX SEVEN DOLLARS
GAS RIGHT THEY WOULD HAVE TO SEE
THIS BENEFITS THEM- THIS MOVE
AND WE CAN'T DO THAT WITHOUT
REAL PLANNING AND REAL FOUGHT
WITH REAL INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AS YOU KNOW MOST
PEOPLE CHARGE AT HOME TO
INVESTMENTS IN INFRASTRUCTURE AS
WELL AS IN VEHICLES- SO I
APPRECIATE. EVERYONE'S COMMENTS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
TWELVE FIFTY ONE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE DODD I THOUGHT I'D
NIELSEN ALLEN. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HI BAKER
BAKER I WERE JUST GORGEOUS NO
BRADFORD GLAZER WESO JONES
KAMLAGER MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO AYE WILK
ON CULTURE THANK YOU THE BILL'S
ON CALL WE'RE MOVING NOW TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B. TWELVE
OH THREE BY CENTER BACKER. YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU BUT CHAIR
MEMBERS. SB TWELVE A THREE IS
ABOUT HAVING THE STATE
GOVERNMENT'S AN EXAMPLE. BY
GETTING TO NET ZERO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSION EMISSIONS ITSELF
BEFORE ASKING EVERYONE ELSE IN
THE STATE TO DO SO. CALIFORNIA'S
BEEN LEADING THE WORLD REDUCE
OUR EMISSIONS AND ASCETICAL FOR
THE WHOLE STATE TO BE NET ZERO
BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE. WEST IN
OUR COMPANIES AND OUR CITIZENS
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS DRAMATICALLY IN ORDER
TO HIT THAT TARGET. I BELIEVE
THAT WE IN STATE GOVERNMENT NEED
TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE. THIS BILL
SETS A PLANNING GOAL FOR ALL OF
OUR STATE AGENCIES TO AIM TO
ACHIEVE NET ZERO FROM THEIR OWN
EMISSIONS BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
TEN YEARS AHEAD OF THE STATE AS
A WHOLE. THAT MEANS REDUCE
EMISSIONS FOR STATE AGENCIES
BUILDINGS AND VEHICLES EVAN
ELECTRICITY THEY CONSUME.
REQUIRES AGENCIES TO PUT
TOGETHER PLANS TO IDENTIFY WHAT
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO GET TO THIS
YEAR BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. AND
HOW MUCH IT WILL COST
INTRODUCTION TO INCLUDE THOSE
ACTIONS IN THE PLANNING PROCESS
SEES. AN BUDGET REQUESTS. THIS
BILL WE'RE BUILDING A WORK THAT
MANY FIRST AGENCIES HAVE ALREADY
BEEN DOING. IN REPORTING THEIR
EMISSIONS INVENTORIES ANNUALLY
AND MAKING PROGRESS ON REDUCING
EMISSIONS SINCE TWENTY TEN. THIS
BILL PROVIDES A CLEAR TARGET TO
MOTIVATE CONTINUED PROGRESS. TO
ALLOW AGENCIES TO ACHIEVE NET
ZERO AS COST EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE. THE BILL PROVIDES
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY IN THE
TECHNOLOGIES AND APPROACHES
AVAILABLE. IT ALSO DIRECTS DCS
IS OFFICE OF SUSTAINABILITY TO
ACCESS THE CENTRE OF EXPERTISE
AND ASSIST OTHER AGENCIES AND
PLANNING EXECUTION. WHAT THE
QUESTIONS ARE OFTEN HERE IS
WHETHER IT'S REALLY FEASIBLE FOR
STATE AGENCIES TO GET TO KNOW
ZERO BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
BECAUSE WE CAN BE CONFIDENT THAT
IN ITS YOUR TARGET IS
ACHIEVABLE. BECAUSE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SYSTEM IS ALREADY
SHOWING US HOW. IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN THE UC SYSTEM SET A
TARGET FOR SELF TO BE NET ZERO
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. NOT
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. GIVEN THE HOMES THEMSELVES
ABOUT THE SAME OUT OF LEAD TIME
IS THIS BILL WOULD GET BETWEEN
NOW AND TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. AND
THE REPORT BE ON TRACK TO
ACHIEVE THAT TARGET IN JUST A
COUPLE MORE YEARS. AGAIN THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE OFF EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS THAT WILL PLAY PARTLY
THROUGH OFFSETS IN THE HAVE TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION ABOUT-
WHAT. ARE HIGH QUALITY OFFSETS
IN WITH THOSE- AGREED TO BE. I
DO NOT TO CONCERNED AGENCIES
HAVE NOT YET DEVELOPED PLANS.
FOR GETTING THAT ZERO. AND I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES THE CRIME
WORKING GROUP FOR THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION ON THIS TICKET TO
REMAIN. AND SO WE- AND WE NEED A
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE
FEASIBILITY AND COST OF
ACHIEVING THE NETS RECALL ONCE
THEY DO SO. SO AGAIN PASSING
THIS BILL WE'VE MADE THIS BILL.
IS NOT A BINDING COMMITMENT TO
THAT ZERO BY TWENTY THIRD FEB
WERE COMMITTING TO UNKNOWN
FUTURE BUDGET EXPENDITURES. THE
LEGISLATURE WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DECIDE HOW FAR.
AND HOW FAST. YOU GO THROUGH
FUTURE BUDGET PROCREATION ONCE
THOSE PLANS ARE DEVELOPED. FOR
THIS BILL WILL BE AN IMPORTANT
FIRST STEP TOWARDS UNDERSTANDING
WHAT IS GOING ON WHAT'S GOING TO
TAKE. TO GET TO KNOW ZERO. AND
HAVING THE WHOLE STATE
GOVERNMENT START HEADING IN THAT
DIRECTION. I'M AGAIN ONCE THEY
GET KNOWLEDGE THAT SECOND
GROUP'S ASSISTANCE. A PARTICULAR
CENTER BY CAL SKI CENTER
CABALLERO. IMPROVING THIS BILL
ALONG WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
EXPECT TO ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
HERE'S A WITNESS I HAVE CAITLYN
ROGER SUTTER FROM EDF SHE'S A
SENIOR MANAGER OF U. S. CLIMATE
POLICY. SIR PLEASE BEGIN. WHEN
RATHER SUTTER SENIOR MANAGER FOR
U. S. CLIMATE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND I'M PLEASED TO JOIN
YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR
BACKERS SB TWELVE OH THREE TO
ESTABLISH A GOAL FOR ALL STATE
AGENCIES TO ACHIEVE NET ZERO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. AS
YESTERDAY'S INTERGOVERNMENTAL
PANEL ON CLIMATE CHANGE REPORT
ONCE AGAIN MADE CLEAR. THE WORLD
IS SWIFTLY MOVING TOWARD ONE
POINT FIVE DEGREES OF WARMING.
BUT THE REPORT ALSO MAKES CLEAR
THAT. WE HAVE THE TOOLS THE
TECHNOLOGY IN THE RESOURCES TO
MAKE THE NECESSARY TRANSITION.
SB TWELVE OH THREE IS ONE STEP
IN THIS TRANSITION FOR
CALIFORNIA BY ASKING STATE
AGENCIES TO INVENTORY THEIR
EMISSIONS TO SET INTERIM TARGETS
FOR REDUCING THEIR EMISSIONS
TOWARD NET ZERO. AND DEVELOP A
PATH TO MEET THOSE TARGETS
CALIFORNIA WILL TAKE A BIG STEP
FORWARD IN UNDERSTANDING HOW TO
ULTIMATELY ACHIEVE NET ZERO
EMISSIONS ECONOMY WIDE. FULL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AGENCY'S
PLANS WILL STILL BE CONTINGENT
ON FUELPERKS FUTURE
APPROPRIATIONS BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO THIS BODY CAN
DETERMINE HOW TO PRIORITIZE
STATEWIDE EMISSION REDUCTIONS.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG BEEN A
CLIMATE LEADER AND ASKING THE
STATE GOVERNMENT TO DEVELOP
PLANS TO ACHIEVE NET ZERO
CONTRIBUTES TO THIS LEGACY AND
LEVERAGES THE STATE'S
PROCUREMENT POWER TO SPUR DEMAND
FOR NEW CLEAN TECHNOLOGIES. AS
WELL AS CREATING A PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS ACROSS OUR STATE. SB
TWELVE OH THREE IS ALSO A STEP
THAT MANY OTHER STATES CAN
FOLLOW FURTHER ENHANCING
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE. THE
IPCC REPORT IS ENCOURAGING AND
THAT IT IN FOR IT AFFIRMS THAT
WE HAVE THE KNOW HOW TO ADDRESS
RAPID CHANGES IN OUR CLIMATE.
BUT IT'S ALSO CLEAR THE
POLITICAL WILL IS HOLDING THE
WORLD BACK FROM DEPLOYING THOSE
TOOLS AND RESOURCES. THE
CALIFORNIA HAS THE POLITICAL
WILL TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE
NOW IS YET ONE MORE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BAKER FOR INTRODUCING
THIS BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR AYE
VOTES ON SB TWELVE OH THREE.
THANK YOU MICELLAR WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ANYONE HERE AT THE CHAMBER
ANYBODY ELSE THE CHAMBER
WISHING. TO ADDRESS ON THIS
BILL- SEEING NONE- MODERATOR- IF
YOU COULD PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE OH
THREE. PLEASE OPEN THE LINES ARE
CALLED SUPPORT WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY AND WE CAN CONTINUE
. THANK YOU IT OPERATES AT
SUPPORT FOR SB TROUBLE THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AGAIN ONE ZERO. IT WAS MOMENT
HERE.
AND NOW WE CAN OPEN THE LINE OF
MY NUMBER TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS KATHY SAFER
FOR THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
CLIMATE REALITY PROJECT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND THEN
FURTHER AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATOR CAN WE NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN YOUR
FROM THE OPPOSITION IF ANY. AND
IF YOU LIKE TO OFFER OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEY ARE AT
THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLY NINE Q.
MONTEREY I'M SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR
EITHER. I'M SORRY NINETEEN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU PERFECT
THANK OU VERY MUCH SO WE'RE
GONNA MOVE THAT- DISCUSSION BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS IS THERE ANYBODY-
WISHING TO ADDRESS- THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS- ON THIS BILL
. AND SEEING NONE- CENTER BACK
OR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES
I WANTED TO I THINK- WITNESS IN
OUR SEARCH WESTERN I'VE A- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SB TWELVE OH THREE.
CENTER ARCHULETA MOVES. I THANK
YOU THE BILL'S BEEN NEARBY
CENTER ARCHULETA. MOTIONS TO
PASTOR OF OUR MIDDLE QUALITY
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. HI DON I NIELSEN ALLEN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BAKER
AYE BAKER AYE BORJAS. BRADFORD
GLAZER GLAZER HI WESO JONES
KAMLAGER MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO AYE WILK
. THIRTY ONE SHERMAN ON CALL.
THE BILL IS ON CLL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER BIT- BAKER I
WILL NOW THE- MOVED TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB EIGHT NINE TWO BY
CENTER HER TADO. SENATOR HER
TADO. EUROPE.
A GOOD MORNING M. MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. IN RECENT YEARS THE
UNITED STATES HAS SEEN AN
INCREASE IN ATTACKS ARE TOWARDS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE SECTORS
INCLUDING ITS AGRICULTURE AND
WATER SECTORS. THESE THREATS
INCREASINGLY BOTH FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC COULD HAVE DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES ULTIMATELY
AFFECTING BOTH THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY. OF CALIFORNIANS AND THE
ECONOMIC STRENGTH OF CALIFORNIA
AS A WHOLE. THE CYBER ATTACKS
AFFECT THE INTEGRITY OF OUR FOOD
AND WATER AND THESE CREATE
UNCERTAINTY THAT CAN LEAD TO
INCREASED RISK TO OUR FOOD
SUPPLY CHAIN. A BROKEN FOOD
SUPPLY CHAIN WOULD HAVE A
DISPROPORTIONATE EFFECT ON OUR
MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
LIVING TO INCREASE PRICES AND
LESS FOOD AVAILABILITY. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ALREADY THAT
WERE ALREADY SEEN DUE TO THE
LACK OF WATER FROM DOCTOR
DROUGHT AND MANY CALIFORNIANS
ARE ALREADY EXPERIENCED THIS AT
THE GROCERY STORE. ADDITIONALLY
AS OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
NOTED WE NEEDED TO STRENGTH WE
NEED TO STRENGTHEN OUR CYBER
PREPAREDNESS IN THE WAKE OF AN
INCREASING PROBABILITY. OF
RUSSIAN CYBER ATTACKS. FOR
EXAMPLE OF WE KNOW THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST OFFICE IN
CONDUCTING SOME RESEARCH FOUND
THAT. AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
CYBER ATTACKS- HAVE BEEN DOWN
HERE AND IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
TWENTY AN ESTIMATED FORTY SEVEN
THOUSAND CYBERATTACKS WITH
PAYOUTS TOTALING ONE POINT TWO
BILLION WERE REPORTED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IN THE
FIRST SIX MONTHS OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND CYBERATTACKS HAD
ALREADY BEEN REPORTED IN THE
STATE REPRESENTING IT IN AN
ANNUAL INCREASE OF 62% IF TRENDS
CONTINUE. WHAT ALL THIS IN MIND
IT IS INCREASINGLY NECESSARY FOR
STATE TO STATE PROACTIVE IN
ENSURE WE ARE PREPARED IN THE
EVENT OF A CYBER ATTACK ON THESE
CRITICAL SECTORS. SB EIGHT
NINETY TWO ISSUES OPTIONAL
REPORTING GUIDELINES AROUND
CALIFORNIA'S FOOD AND WATER
SECTORS AND IT ENCOURAGES OUR
STATE CYBERSECURITY AGENCIES. TO
STRENGTHEN OUR STATE
CYBERSECURITY DEFENSES. SB EIGHT
NINE TWO ENCOURAGES ENTITIES IN
THE FOOD AND AGRICULTURE SECTOR
AND WATER AND WASTE WATER SECTOR
TO REPORT INSTANCES OF A
VERIFIED CYBERTHREAT. OR CYBER
ATTACK WITHIN THIRTY DAYS TO
RELEVANT TECHNOLOGY BASED STATE
AGENCIES THIS THE BILL ALSO
DIRECTS OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IN THE CYBER SECURITY
INTEGRATIONS TO DEVELOP PLANS TO
INCREASE OUTREACH FOR
CYBERSECURITY PREPAREDNESS AS
WELL AS IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
FUNDING SOURCES THAT SUPPORT
CYBERSECURITY BUT PLACING A
STRONGER FOCUS ON CYBERSECURITY
NOW AND RECOGNIZING ITS
IMPORTANCE TO CALIFORNIA'S.
AGRICULTURE AND WATER SECTORS SB
EIGHT EIGHT TWO ALLOWS
CALIFORNIA TAKE A MUCH NEEDED
STEP IN THE DIRECTION OF CYBER
CYBERSECURITY PREPAREDNESS- AND
I HAVE ONE WITNESS TODAY JOINING
US REMOTELY AND THAT'S OUR
JUSTICE GARBA POLICY TRIP FOR
THE CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION
. HE THE WITNESS MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
A COMEDIAN COUNTERTOP THANK YOU-
AS SENATOR THOMAS AND I'M THE
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA WATER
ASSOCIATIONS PUBLIC POLICY
COMMITTEE THE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTS THE MORE THAN NINETY
WATER SUPPLIERS THAT ARE
REGULATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION-
TOGETHER WE PROVIDE SAFE CLEAN
AND PORTABLE DRINKING WATER
SERVICE TO ABOUT SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIANS- I CAN SURELY LIKE
TO THANK SENATOR TADO FOR
OPENING DISCUSSION ON THIS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TOPIC AND
BRING FORWARD SENATE BILL EIGHT
NINE TWO- HER STAFF AND SHE
HERSELF HAD BEEN ABSOLUTELY
FANTASTIC TO WORK WITH. THREE
THAT HIGH RISK SO IMPORTANT
WATERSHED. IS QUITE SIMPLE WE
PROVIDE THE ONLY PUBLIC UTILITY
SERVICE FOR CONGESTED. ENSURING
THE SAFETY WATER WE PROVIDED
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL AND IT'S ONE
OF THOSE THINGS THAT WE JUST
CAN'T EVER GET WRONG- AND ON THE
ON THE FLIP SIDE WE FACE MERRY.
THREATS CYBERSECURITY TRACKS AS
WITH MOST THINGS MANY PORTIONS
OF STATE WATER SYSTEMS ARE
CONTROLLED REMOTELY. OPEN UNITED
THEM UP TO POTENTIAL
CYBERATTACKS. JUST LAST YEAR WAS
WIDELY REPORTED THAT HACKERS- IN
THE BAY AREA WILL BE ABLE TO I
BELIEVE SOME OF THE PROGRAMS
USED TO OPERATE A WATER
TREATMENT PLANT THAT. SUPPLIES
WATER TO CUSTOMERS IN THE BAY
AREA. AND WHILE THIS TAP WAS
CAUGHT AND ADDRESSED IN TIME.
RELYING ON LUCK IT'S NOT A SOUND
STRATEGY- NOT ONLY CAN FIBER
CARE ACT AFFECT THE SAFETY OF
DRINKING WATER BUT THEY CAN
IMPACT EVERYTHING FROM. THE
SUPPLY OF DRINKING WATER SHE WAS
SIMPLY THE LOSS OF CUSTOMER-
YEAH- AND THE LOSS OF PUBLIC A-
PUBLIC IDEA PUBLICLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION. AND
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT THE
WATER SECTOR FACES IS THE LACK
OF STATE. UNIFORMS BEING FEDERAL
CYBERSECURITY STANDARDS FOR
WATER SUPPLIERS THE PROBLEM.
ASSEMBLE A NINETY WILL HELP
CLOSE THAT GAP. AND WE TRULY
APPRECIATE SENATOR THOMAS WORK
ON THIS IMPORTANT VITAL TOPIC.
IF YOU ALL HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I
MORE THAN- MIGHT HAVE TO GET
DRESSED US BUT IT'S NOT THANK
YOU ALL SO MUCH. OF TIME WE
APPRECIATE IT. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH I SEE NO. IN THE CHAIN.
IT'S WISHING TO- COMMIT ON THIS
IS. BY WILL NOT. MOVE ON. TO
THE- TELL. ALLIANCE IN. CALL
SUPPORT WITH THIS IS
INDIVIDUALLY. PLEASE PROCEED
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND CURRENTLY NINE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATOR IF WE COULD DO
THE SAME THING NOW FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. AND PROPOSED PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. GIVE US JUST A
MOMENT HERE.
YOU HAVE ONE OF MEDIUM AS WE
GATHER THEIR LINE AND WE HAVE A
COUPLE IN Q. HERE. AND WE CAN GO
TO LINE NUMBER NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS GAIL
BELL HANNAH WITH WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION I'M ALSO- BEGIN ON
BEHALF OF THE FARM BUREAU AND
AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA IF THE MAKE PINE
CREEK MORNING WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THE BILL BUT WE DO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR WORKING WITH US. ON
OUR CONCERN- WE DO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERN OVER CYBER SECURITY
PROBLEMS AND ISSUES- BUT
CURRENTLY HAVE DRAFTED WE ARE- A
LITTLE BIT UNSURE HOW IT WOULD
WORK THROUGHOUT. EACH OF THE
FARMS AND RANCHES IN CALIFORNIA.
SO I DO THINK THE SENATOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS BILL AND
WORKING WITH US- AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD THAT WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED. AT THIS POINT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ACTUALLY GO
TO LINE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS
AND THREE MILLION ON BEHALF OF
GLACIAL WATER DISTRICT A WEEK
YOU ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSED UNLESS
DIMINISH THE BILL HOWEVER WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE OFFER TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS OF THE BOARD. THANK YOU
. AND THEN FURTHER AT THIS TIME
. GET YOURS WE HAVE SOMEBODY IN
THE GALLERY IF YOU LIKE TO-
PRESENT OUT PLEASE PROCEED. SO
MANY OTHERS HERE TODAY HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BUT APPRECIATE THE WORK WE'VE
ALREADY DONE WITH THE AUTHOR
TODAY AND ARE CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH HER ON AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL AND BELIEVE IT'S MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. THE PEERS
OF WE'RE DONE WITH THE-
WITNESSES- DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I ALSO- JUST WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS BEEN WORKING WITHOUT
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION. AND I
CAN APPRECIATE WHAT THE OP HAS
STAYED AND YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND
WHY YOU ARE OLD ENOUGH THAT I
JUST WANT A LITTLE BIT
CLARIFICATION IF I MAY ADDRESS
THE AUTHOR. QUESTION TO THE
OTHER. WE ARE AND THAT IS YOU
KNOW AS I'M READING THE BILL AND
I THINK I READ SOME OF THE
INFORMATION THAT ALSO CAME FROM
THE OPPOSITION. I'M READING HERE
THAT IT'S COMPLETELY OPTIONAL
AND THEY HAVE THE OPTION TO
SIMPLY OPT OUT CAN YOU CLARIFY
THAT FOR ME PLEASE. YOU SO. THE
BILL WAS AMENDED AT BECAUSE OF
THE CONCERNS THAT THE OPPOSITION
RAISED- IN REGARDS TO- MANDATING
RIGHT- AT BECAUSE THERE'S
ALREADY REPORTING THAT IS DONE.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND SO. I
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT- IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE TO BE.
ON FOR YOU HAVE YOUR SITE AT.
LIKE INFRASTRUCTURE GOT IT WE
GOT TO BE ABLE TO STAY THAT AS
PER WITH A IN FOR. AND SO WE OF
COURSE WANT TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS AND WE MADE IT UP
OPTIONAL REPORTING. I SO IT'S NO
LONGER ADD MANDATORY. THANK YOU
FOR THAT SO I THINK THAT'S WHERE
I GUESS I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THERE'S
OPPOSITION BUT WHEN I SEE THAT
THIS IS COMPLETE. ARE COMPLETELY
OPTIONAL I THINK IT'S WORTH
MOVING FORWARD AND YOU KNOW I'M
A SHIRT BUT BASED ON THE
COMMENTS OF THE OPPOSITION THAT
THE AUTHOR HAS BEEN OPEN TO
WORKING WITH THEM AND- AND I
THINK THE FACT THAT IT'S
COMPLETELY OPTIONAL I THINK
THAT- IT SHOULD MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU AND WITH THAT I WITH
THE BILL. THANK U. S. SENATOR
RUBIO ANYBODY ELSE WISHING.
SEEING NONE SUTTER TODD WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE YES I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR- AND TO
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING WITH-
MY OFFICE ON- SUMMIT ON SOME OF
THESE AMENDMENTS WE APPRECIATE
THE WORK AND OF COURSE WE'LL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU
OPPOSITION. TO OUR CORPORATE OF
REMAINING CONCERNS THAT ARE-
LEFT BUT ASIDE FROM THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DAUGHTER THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY CENTER
RUBIO THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. DOT BY THOUGHT
I'D NIELSEN ALLEN ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA HI BAKER BAKER HI
GORGEOUS OFFERED GLAZER GLAZER
HI WESO JONES KAMLAGER MILLION.
POURTANT PORTANTINO HI RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WILK. SIX ZERO GERMAN
CLASSICS THAT BUT BILLS ON CALL
THANK YOU SIR- WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB NINE NINE THREE BY
SENATOR SKINNER SENATOR
APOLOGIES FOR- THE HEAVY WEIGHT
- APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NOT A
PROBLEM I JUST WAS- BUT I'VE NOT
THE CHAIR OF A CERTAIN COMMITTEE
BUT I ENDED UP HAVING TO BE THE
CHAIR THIS MORNING AND SO HAD TO
LEAVE AND- BUT I WILL RETURN
THERE. ALL RIGHT SO I AM
PRESENTING SB NINE NINE THREE.
WHICH IS GOING TO MAKE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO OUR VICTIMS
COMPENSATION. OF PROCESS AND
ALSO SOME- REVISIONS TO OUR
FLEXIBLE ASSISTANCE. SURVIVORS
OF VIOLENCE. ON GRANT PROGRAM.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ESTABLISH THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD WHICH
PROVIDES FINANCIAL SUPPORT AND
SERVICES TO CRIME VICTIMS AND TO
EXONERATE. NOW WHAT WE'VE FOUND
AND THERE'S GOOD DATA SUPPORTING
THIS THAT PROVIDING SUCH
SUPPORT. INCREASES COMMUNITY
SAFETY. IMPROVES THE TRUST
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
VICTIMS AND LEAVES. RETIRED
REDUCES RETALIATION CRIMES THAT
CAN OCCUR WHEN THE VICTIM OF
CRIME FEELS THAT THERE ARE NOT
THAT THE- THERE'S NOT BEEN AN
APPROPRIATE RESPONSE THEY'VE NOT
BEEN ASSISTED HERE'S YOU KNOW
THE CRIME IS NOT BEING SOLVED
AND WE HAVE SEEN IN MANY CASES
WHERE. CRIME IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES ENDS UP BEING THIS-
CYCLE OF KIND OF RETALIATORY
CRIMES WHICH DOES NOT BENEFIT
ANYONE. NOW THIS IMPORTANT
SERVICE IS UNDERFUNDED AND
GOVERNED BY STATUTORY LANGUAGE
THAT HAS PREVENTED MANY CRIME
SURVIVORS FROM BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS FUNDS OR RECEIVE THE HELP
THEY NEED. AND DISTINCTIONS
ABOUT WHO DESERVES HELP WHEN
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED A CRIME
LEAVES MANY VICTIMS LEAVING
FEELING LEFT OUT OF THE
PROTECTION OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
SYSTEM IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
AND I THINK ALL OF US KNOW. IF
WE ANY OF US ARE EVER SUBJECT TO
A VIOLENT CRIME WE'RE OTHER
CRIME THAT WE ALL DESERVE
SUPPORT IF THE STATE HAS
DEVELOPED A SYSTEM TO PROVIDE
SUCH SUPPORT. WHAT SB NINE NINE
THREE DOES IS IMPROVES ACCESS TO
SUPPORT AND SERVICES FOR
SURVIVORS OF CRIME AND TO
EXONERATION THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO
WERE. WRONGFULLY CONVICTED AND
INCREASES THE FINANCIAL SUPPORT
A CRIME SURVIVOR CAN RECEIVE AND
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK MY
WITNESSES- TOUR HERE- I BELIEVE
ON A CALL LINE TO PROVIDERS-
CAST MONIQUE. AND MY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. CARTOONISH ROLLINS
WHO IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CRIME SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND MARK HUGHES THE
DIRECTOR OF YOUTH ALIVE WHICH IS
A VIOLENCE INTERVENTION PROGRAM.
THANK YOU SENATOR- MISS HOLLINS
I BELIEVE YOU'RE IN THE CHAMBER
HERE. I AM THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING TO THE CHAIR INTO THE
SENATORS MY NAME IS TO ME
SILENCE I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS SAFETY
AND JUSTICE. ALSO THE STATE
DIRECTOR OF CRIME SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE WHICH IS THE
STATE'S LARGEST NETWORK OF
VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS. CCJ IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR SB NINE THREE
THREE AND I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK SENATOR SKINNER
FOR CHAMPIONING. THIS
GROUNDBREAKING LEGISLATION.
BEFORE I BEGIN I WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SEND PRAYER AND
CONDOLENCES TO THE VICTIMS AND
SURVIVING FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
WERE IMPACTED BY THE MASS
SHOOTING THAT TOOK PLACE. JUST A
BLOCK AWAY FROM THIS BUILDING.
AND I SPENT THIS MORNING READING
THE NAMES OF HOSE ITEMS ARE
LEARNING ABOUT THEIR LOVED ONES
AS THEY DESCRIBE THEM AND THOSE
WHO WERE LEFT BEHIND. AS A
SURVIVING FAMILY MEMBER OF TWO
HOMICIDE VICTIMS SOMEONE WHO
LOVES TO READ AND THEN VIOLENCE
IN THE TRAUMA. I UNDERSTAND THE
TRAUMA THAT CAUSED. DAMAGE TO MY
IMMEDIATE FAMILY I UNDERSTAND
WITH THE VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
OF THIS EXPERIENCE ARE GOING
THROUGH. SOME OF THOSE JOBS
HOMES SO MAY LITERALLY LOSE LIVE
I'M SELF MEDICATING IN BEING
UNABLE TO COPE WITH THE PAIN OF
THE PROBLEM. LYFT COMES VERY
COMPLICATED EXPENSIVE AND
CONFUSING FOR VICTIMS AND FAMILY
MEMBERS AFTER CRIME IN ANY
BARRIER TO GETTING HELP OR
SUPPORT CAUSES MORE TRAUMA IT
CAN PLACE PEOPLE IN DANGER. IN
THIS MOMENT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
WE ASSESS THE NEEDS OF ALL
VICTIMS THIS IS THE IN THE BEST
IT IS THE SAFE. AND IT THE NIGHT
HE IS A BILL. THAT WILL HELP
MAKE THAT HAPPEN MAKE THAT REAL
. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES
COME. FOR NATIONAL LEAGUE.
FORTUNE TOO MANY PEOPLE IN LEGAL
BAY TO HIM THIS BILL WOULD
REMOVE DOZEN OF LEGAL BARRIERS
IN PREVENT PREVENT CRIME AND SO
WILL GIVE SYSTEM IT WOULD REDUCE
TAPE IN THE APPLICATION PROCESS
INCREASED FLEXIBILITY IN FUNDS
INCREASE RESPONSE TIME FOR FOLKS
MAKE SURE THAT THE OUT REACH
PROGRAMS REALLY TOUCH THE
COMMUNITY AND THE PEOPLE
ACTUALLY GET ACCESS TO THE HELP
THAT THEY NEED IT WOULD LESSEN
THE RATE VARIES THAT HAVE. ANY
PEOPLE THAT ARE MOST. BY CRIME
FROM GETTING THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED. AGAIN HELPING VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS IS IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF PUBLIC SAFETY IN
THE STATE. AND WE WANT
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO LEAD
THE WAY IN SAFETY INTO MAKING
SURE THE VICTIMS AND SURVIVORS
GET HELP. TODAY WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE N SUPPORT OF
SB NINE THREE THREE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WE HAVE NOW- IS IT
THIS FALL INTO MISS MARK ON THE-
THIS MARKS THIS MAR- YOU BASED
YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- IN MARCH AND I JUST WANT
TO APPRECIATE BETTER- ALSO
CALLING FOR YOUR PROPERTY TO
SHOW ON THE ISSUE. WITH A LOT
ABOUT THE DUTCH OVER THE THAT
OPEN. WITHOUT CONTRACTED BY. AND
TOP OF FAMILIES CONNECTED
INCLUDED OVER HUNDRED EIGHTY.
YEAH PAST YEAR. THE TERM. THEY
DIDN'T. THE CARD AND OTHER ALLOW
. OKAY TO THE CARD IT FROM WELL
HE HAD BEEN SHOT CAUGHT IN
CROSSFIRE. HOSPITAL CO HE DID
THE POLITICAL TO THE. HI
EDUCATED ALSO HIGHLIGHTED LITTLE
TOO WOULD HAVE PAID WHO IS NOW I
DO KNOW- AND THE BILL ROOM KEY
DESCRIPTORS TO VIEW THEM WITH
THE DETAILS OF THE.
WHAT A ONE BILLION NEEDED AFTER
A VIOLENT INCIDENT MAY NOT
OPERATE IMMEDIATELY WITH POLICE
AND YET THE POLITICAL CALLING ON
COOPERATIVE AND THEIR DIFFERENT
COMPETITION PARTICULAR THE-
CRITICAL BILL. SIXTY TAP PROBLEM
IF YOU'RE PPL LIVED ON EDGE
DON'T FEEL SAFE LATE NOT BE
STATE DIDN'T HAVE BEEN CHOI. OF
THEIR OWN. FIFTY THIRTY THIRTY
HAS BEACH BETTER HE.
CONDITIONALLY VICTOR. TWENTY OF
THE CAR THAT WE TAKE. ANY
PARTICULAR. PROVIDE WITH YOU TO
MAKE COMPETITION AUTHORED.
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. X. GOOD
MORNING JERRY DODD AND SENATORS
MOSTLY BECAUSE ON BEHALF OF
SPONSORS CALIFORNIA PERCEIVED
INJUSTICE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED MEMBERS A LITTLE
WITH CALIFORNIA CRIME SURVIVORS
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LOOKS LIKE
WERE UPSIDE DOWN THERE-
MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE THREE
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE TO CALL
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALLY PLEASE. THANK YOU.
FOR SB FIVE SORRY. I'M PRETTY
WELL GO AHEAD NOW OPEN LINE BY
PRESSING ONE. THE I. NUMBER.
THIRTY SIX. GOOD MORNING SIR
MEMBERS NICOLE KIANA ON BEHALF
OF EVERY TOWN FOR GUN SAFETY AND
SUPPORT. AMONG MANY. THANK YOU
IN Q. AND TO SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE
IT IS ONE AND THEN THERE. TWENTY
NINE FORTY ONE. HI MY NAME IS
HANNAH **** CALLING ON BEHALF OF
COWBOYS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU SO MUCH. IN A SINGLE LINE.
NUMBER. THANK FORTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS EVAN ONE
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTER
SB NINE NINE THREE ON BEHALF OF
BUILT ENVIRONMENT THANK YOU.
NINE SEVEN. EXAMINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. DAVID MADDOCK IN WHAT AT
THE JUSTICE GROUP AND SUPPORT.
AND BLACK FIGURE OUT WHAT WENT
OVER HERE WE AT LINE TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RON ELDON
DIRECTOR AFTER CAN ATTEND IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE MORE HERE
JUST GIVE ME A MOMENT HERE. LINE
FORTY EIGHT BUT. HELLO MY NAME
IS DANIEL MEADOW WITH DIGNITY
AND POWER NOW IN THE CARE FOR
CALIFORNIA COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORTER AND SB NINE NINE THREE. AND CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER IN
Q. THANK YOU MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM THE SUPPORTERS WILL
NOT FALL THE SAME PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE CHAMBER.
SEEING NONE- THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL NOW A MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY. VIA
TELECONFERENCE ARVEST COULD YOU
PLEASE PROP THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND PUT THEM ON INDIVIDUALLY
PLEASE. WHAT I'M. CURRENTLY NINE
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE- ANYBODY THAT- WAS-
TESTIFYING- EITHER IN OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL DO ANY
OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I SEE
CENTER ARCHER LET US MIKE IS UP
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I CERTAINLY WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE AUTHOR-
SB NINE NINE THREE. WHAT A
WONDERFUL BILL AND I AM I AM SO
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE BILL I'D
LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR BUT I'D
LIKE TO POINT OUT THE- THE
SENSITIVITY THAT IT EXPRESSES
DRUG KNOWLEDGE THAT SO MANY
FAMILIES THAT ARE VICTIMS OF
CRIME A FIND THEMSELVES- NOT
KNOWING WHERE TO GO AND WHO TO
SEEK. BUT NOW THIS BILL WILL
OPEN UP SOME DOORS IN THE
SURVIVORS OF CAN YOU IMAGINE
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE IN OUR OWN
SACRAMENTAL THE FAMILIES WHAT
THEY FEEL THE TRAGEDIES THAT
JUST HAPPENED WHERE ARE THEY
TURNING TO HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
GET HELP. AND SENATE BILL NINE
NINE THREE WILL OPEN DOORS- IT
IS SO IMPORTANT WE RECOGNISE
FAMILIES IN THE MENTAL HEALTH
SITUATION THAT'S GOING ON RIGHT
NOW THE ANGUISH THE PAIN- AND
THE EXPENSE OF THE FUNERALS IN
STRONG ONE. I THINK THIS IS A
GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL OF US
IN THE SENATE TO REACH OUT TO
THE COMMUNITY AND SAY WE DO CARE
ABOUT THE VICTIMS WE DO CARE
ABOUT THE VICTIMS OF CRIME AND
THAT WE'RE TAKING THIS STEP
FORWARD. AND ONCE AGAIN I AM SO
HONORED THAT THIS BILL IS BEFORE
US BECAUSE IT TOUCHES US ALL SO
I. OBVIOUSLY URGENT AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. KEEP CENTER RUBY.
THANK MISTER TERM I ALSO WANT TO
COMMEND THE THERE FOR WONDERFUL
BELL I THINK IT'S IT IS
IMPORTANT AS NECESSARY AND AS
THE AUTHOR STATED- THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION IS ALREADY IT'S
COVERED BY STATUTORY LANGUAGE IN
ITS THEY ALREADY HAVE SO MANY
BARRIERS AND SO MANY OF THE RED
TAPE AND WHATEVER WE CAN DO TO
GET ON THE SUPPORT AND THE HELP
THEY NEED I THINK IT'S NECESSARY
I THINK IN MY PERSONAL OPINION.
THE TRAGEDY DOESN'T JUST STOP
WITH THE CRIME IT'S WHAT'S LEFT
IN THE AFTERMATH WITH FAMILIES
TRYING TO PUT THE PIECES
TOGETHER WITH YOU KNOW VICTIM
STRUGGLING TO RECOVER AND
EVERYTHING THAT COMES WITH IT SO
I'MREALLY PLEASED TO SEE THIS
BILL MOVE FORWARD IN ANYTHING
AGAIN THAT WE CAN DO TO INCREASE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT SO THEY CAN
GET. THE HELP THAT THEY NEED I
THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE ON BOARD
AND I ALSO WOULD LIKE TO ADD AS
A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU. AND I
CONSIDER THAT A MOTION CENTER
RUBIO. SKEWS ME SUTTER AS OF
SERGEANTS YOUR MIND THAT'S OKAY
MISTER CHAIRMAN I PUT IT UP A
LITTLE LATE APOLOGIES- SO I WILL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY BY
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS I
WANNA MAKE- I THINK WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT. THE
FUNDING FOR THIS TYPE OF
PROGRAM- IS AT RISK IT IS
NEARING INSOLVENCY IN OVER. THE
COURSE OF MANY YEARS THIS BODY
HAS. DECREASED THE ABILITY TO
COLLECT FUNDS FOR THIS PROGRAM
IN THE IN THAT WE HAVE REDUCED
FINES AND FEES- YOU KNOW. FOR-
CHECK TICKETS YOU KNOW TO GET
REVENUE IN PARTICULAR- IN AND
THEN OF COURSE WE'VE INCREASED-
THE ABILITY FOR OTHERS TO
COLLECT FROM THIS BE SO WE'RE
INCREASING NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO
CAN USE THIS REVENUE- WE'RE
DECREASING THE AMOUNT OF REVENUE
AND WE DON'T HAVE A DURING A
DEDICATED FUNDING STREAM FOR
THIS AND THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED OTHERWISE THERE WON'T
BE ANY MONEY FOR ANYBODY IN THE
FUTURE- SO I REALIZE THAT'S NOT
THE POINT OF YOUR BILL SENATORS
SKINNER- AND I APPLAUD YOUR
EFFORTS AND I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL BUT AT SOME POINT THIS
ODY HAS TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
ARE DEPLETING THIS FIND. AND
IT'S NOT GONNA FEEL GOOD ANYMORE
TO SAY YOU'RE EXPANDING THIS
PROGRAM IF THERE'S NOTHING IN IT
TO GET THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- OKAY- THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED. UP BY SENATOR RUBIO. THE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. BUT FIRST CENTER SKINNER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TERROR AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND SENATOR TO LEAD
TO YOUR REFERENCE THE JUST.
HORRIBLE TRAGEDY OF SATURDAY
NIGHT. WITH THAT. MASS SHOOTING.
AND WE I THINK ALL OF US WERE
RELIEVED TO SEE THAT AT LEAST
ONE ARREST HAS BEEN MADE. NOW IN
SUCH AND WE HOPE THAT THE
PERPETRATORS ARE FOUND. AND THAT
WE- THE ANTI- TRIED- HAND THAT
WE GET US A RESOLUTION TO THIS
HORRIBLEMASS SHOOTING BUT WHAT
WE FIND SO OFTEN IN SOME OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE THE
SHOOTINGS OCCURRED. IS THAT
THERE'S- WE NEED COOPERATION
WITH OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
THEM TO BE ABLE TO MAKE IT TO
IDENTIFY SUSPECTS AND MAKE THE
ARRESTS AND THAT IS WHAT'S GOING
TO KEEP US SAFER AND SO THANK
GOODNESS THERE WERE. EITHER
OBSERVERS ARE VICTIMS IN THIS
SITUATION ON SATURDAY NIGHT WHO
COOPERATED WITH THE POLICE THANK
GOODNESS AND THAT'S WHAT WE WANT
TO ACHIEVE AND OF COURSE
PROVIDING SUPPORT TO THOSE
WHO'VE EXPERIENCED THESE AWFUL
INCIDENTS. IS GOING TO ASSIST US
IN DOING THAT NOW I ALSO WANT TO
JUST BE CLEAR IN CASE SOMEONE
FEELS THAT THIS THESE CHANGES
WILL SOMEHOW ONLY BENEFIT
CERTAIN VICTIMS NO WE'RE MAKING
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL IMPROVE
ALL WE'RE NOT CREATING A ZERO
SUM GAME. AND TO SENATOR
MELENDEZ COMMENTS- YES THE
DEPENDENCE THE FUND'S DEPENDENCE
ON THE FINES OR FEES LIKE SO
MANY OF THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE MADE DEPENDENT ON SUCH
THINGS. HAS MADE THE FIND LESS
STABLE AND SO WE WILL IF THIS
BILL IS SUCCESSFUL WE WILL HAVE
TO ADDRESS THAT AND AS THE
BUDGET YEAR. I INTEND TO WHILE I
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO PRESUME
WE HAVE TO SEE HOW THIS PROCEEDS
THROUGH THE PROCESS IT IS
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO DO WHICH IS TO-
ADJUST AND IMPROVE THE FUNDING
SO THAT WE CAN SUPPORT VICTIMS.
ALL CRIME SURVIVORS. AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER. AGAIN
THE- THE IS TO PASS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. DODD HI DOT HI NIELSEN.
ALLEN ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA BAKER
BAKER BAKER I'D GORGEOUS BORDERS
AYE BRADFORD GLAZER GLAZER IGHT
WESO JONES KAMLAGER MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE PORTANTINO RUBIO.
RUBIO HI. SEVEN ZERO TERMINAL
CALL SEVEN ZERO THAT BILLS ON
CALL THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER.
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WELL I DON'T
SEE SENATOR MEN WE IS HERE GREAT
- FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B.
ONE ZERO ZERO ONE FOR THURMOND
YOU BIG BABY YET. CAN'T GIVE ME
THAT EASILY CHAIRED- I THANK YOU
AND MEMBER THANK YOU MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE IN THE STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL- I
RISE TO PRESENT SB ONE THOUSAND
ONE WHICH WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER. ALSO KNOWN
AS CAL CYSTIC TO SUBMIT A REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
FEASIBILITY AND BENEFITS OF
REQUIRING CREDIT REPORTING
BUREAUS AND LENDERS TO UTILIZE
DIFFERENT TYPES OF SECURITY
TACTICS. TO PROTECT CONSUMERS
FROM FINANCIAL FRAUD.
UNFORTUNATELY AS WE ALL KNOW
IDENTITY THEFT AND FINANCIAL
FRAUD ARE IT PER SE PERVASIVE
AND MASSIVELY GROWING PROBLEMS
IN OUR SOCIETY- WITH THE RISE OF
THE INTERNET AND- ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS. I IN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE ALONE THE FEDERAL
TRADE COMMISSION RECEIVED NEARLY
TWO POINT EIGHT MILLION IDENTITY
THEFT INCIDENT REPORTS. WHICH
WAS UP FROM TWO POINT ONE
MILLION. REPORTS RECIBIR PRIOR
AND THE STAFF DO NOT COME
WITHOUT A COST EVERY DAY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES. IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE CONSUMERS
REPORTED LOSING MORE THAN FIVE
POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS TO
FRAUD. INDICATING AN INCREASE OF
MORE THAN 70% FROM TWENTY TWENTY
. THE FULL COST ENERGY THEFT
ATTACKS TO INDIVIDUALS THEIR
LOVED ONES HOWEVER IS DIFFICULT
TO CALCULATE. BECAUSE ONCE A
PERSON'S IDENTIFYING INFORMATION
STOLEN IT CAN POSE A LONG TERM
THREAT TO ONE'S WELL BEING.
CREDIT REPORTING BUREAUS HOUSE
SOME OF OUR MOST SENSITIVE
PERSONAL INFORMATION. THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EQUIFAX DATA
BREACH IS A WAKE UP CALL FOR
EVERYONE PROVING THAT WE NEEDED
TO KEEP UP WITH THE L. VAULTING
IDENTITY THEFT CRIME MARKET. I
PERSONALLY WAS A VICTIM OF THAT
ATTACK MY INFORMATION LIKE MANY
PROBABLY IN THIS CHAMBER WAS
EXPOSED- MY FAMILY AND I WERE
ALSO EXPOSED AS PART OF
SUBSEQUENT BREACH OF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA RESIDENT
EMPLOYEE- AND THEN ALSO WITH T.
MOBILE WE'RE I'M A CUSTOMER. AND
I SAY THIS ONLY TO POINT OUT
THAT. IDENTITY THEFT- ARE LOTS
OF INFORMATION. IS UBIQUITOUS
AND LIKELY TO IMPACT ALMOST ALL
OF US IN THE VERY VERY NEAR
FUTURE. MY KIDS RIGHT NOW I
RECEIVED MAYBE EVERY MONTH OR SO
A REPORT SAYING THAT THEIR
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS ARE ON
THE DARK WEB. ON SO WE NEED SOME
ANSWERS HERE AND THIS IS THE
FIRST STEP TO TRY TO. COME UP
WITH SOME SOLUTIONS. IT WILL
REQUIRE THIS CAL CYSTIC TO
RESEARCH POTENTIAL IDENTITY
THEFT PREVENTION TOOLS.
INCLUDING MULTI FACTOR
AUTHENTICATION EACH TIME A NEW
LINE OF CREDIT IS OPEN OR CREDIT
REPORTS ACCESS. UTILIZING
POTENTIALLY STATEWIDE
ALTERNATIVES TO SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS AS AN AUTHORIZATION.
CLING POTENTIALLY A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER PLUS OR WHAT'S
CALLED A MOBILE DRIVER'S
LICENSE- THIS BILL WILL HELP
INFORM OUR LEGISLATURE HOPEFULLY
WE CAN. WITH THAT INFORMATION
COME UP WITH THE SOLUTIONS- TO
LEAD OUR COUNTRY AS WE'VE ALWAYS
DONE. I IN PROTECTING OUR
CITIZENS FROM IDENTITY THEFT AND
FRAUD. THANK YOU TURNOUT. THANK
YOU ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT THE NOBODY. IN THE
CHAMBERS- OF MODERATOR- CAN WE-
OPEN LINES AND SEE IF ANYBODY IS
ON THE LINE TO SUPPORT OF. SB.
TEN OH ONE. THANK YOU TO SUPPORT
SB CAN A ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IT'S ONE
ZERO. CERTAINLY NOBODY IN Q.
LET'S- I SEE NOBODY IN THE
CHAMBERS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. CAN WE GO THROUGH
THE- THE CALL LINE PLEASE AND-
S. FOR ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB TEN
OH ONE. THANK YOU AND TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CONCURRENTLY NINE Q. OKAY WE'RE
GONNA MOVE- BACK TO- THE
CHAMBERS HERE AND SEE IF ANY
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS
THIS BILL SENATE ARCHULETA. OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION ANYBODY ELSE
SENATOR BORDERS PLEASE. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE WORK
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS DONE AND
CONTINUES TO DO IN THE SPACE- I
THINK- THE WORK THAT WE'VE DONE
IN- CYBERSECURITY AND IDENTITY
THEFT- THIS IS OUR NEW REALITY.
AND WE SHOULDN'T BE LOOKING AT
MANY OF THESE ISSUES TACTICALLY.
BUT MORE- FROM A STRATEGIC
STANDPOINT. DO WE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE WHERE WITH
ALL TO STICK TO KEEP UP AT THE
PACE. THAT MALWARE AND
RANSOMWARE AND IDENTITY THEFT.
OPERATORS WITH THEIR ONGOING
SOPHISTICATION. ARE OPERATING-
TO MATCH OUR TACTICAL MEANS SO I
WANTED TO CONGRATULATE YOU
CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTIVE AND
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU DO.
THANK YOU SENATE. THANK YOU
CENTER MELENDEZ THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN I'M- SENATE SENATOR MAN
. THIS IS GOING TO REQUIRE CAL
CYSTIC TO SUBMIT THEIR REPORT TO
LEGISLATURE IN THE FEASIBILITY
AND BENEFITS OF REQUIRING CREDIT
- CREDIT REPORTING BUREAUS AND
LENDERS TO IMPLEMENT NEW
INFORMATION SECURITY TACTICS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM FINANCIAL
FRAUD- IN THIS AGENCY. I'M
LOOKING AT WHAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE CAN YOU
TELL ME- WHAT SUCCESS THEY HAVE
HAD SO FAR SINCE THEIR INCEPTION
IN THWARTING- THESE TYPES OF
ATTACKS- SO I JUST ACTUALLY
VISITED CAL CYSTIC A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO AS YOU ARE AWARE
CENTER THEY'RE A RELATIVELY NEW
I DON'T BELIEVE IN AGENCY AT
THIS POINT THERE ARE A PART OF
CAL OH YES. MY UNDERSTANDING BUT
THE- HAVE. I THINK BEEN FAIRLY
SUCCESSFUL SO FAR IN TRYING TO
COORDINATE BEST PRACTICES. I AM
TRYING TO FEND OFF. A CYBER
SECURITY TAX- I CAN'T SPEAK TO
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT THEY HAVE
OBSERVE JUST BECAUSE I KNOW SOME
OF THAT SENSITIVE INFORMATION-
BY IN VISITING THEM IN IN
TALKING WITH OTHER AGENCY HEADS
I THINK THAT THERE SO FAR SEEN
AS A KIND OF A MODEL FOR THE
NATION TO FOLLOW. I BELIEVE IN
THE NEAR FUTURE THEY'LL BE
LEADING. A COORDINATION OF A
NUMBERS STATION AND- THE SENSE
THAT I'M GETTING FROM OTHER
STATES AS A CALIFORNIA HAS THE
BEST PRACTICES- SO AS FAR AS
BEATING UP OUR CYBER SECURITY- I
THINK THAT WE'RE DOING. THE
RIGHT JOB I DON'T KNOW TO WHAT
EXTENT WE FENDED OFF.
CYBERSECURITY ATTACKS BUT- BY MY
BELIEF IS YOU KNOW IT WITH IN
CONCERT WITH. SOME OF THE
LEADING. CYBERSECURITY
PREVENTION PRIVATE FIRMS WHICH
ARE BASED IN CALIFORNIA AS YOU
KNOW- THE THEY ARE SEEN AS A- A
GROWING MODEL NOW THIS IS KIND
OF NEW AS FAR AS GOVERNMENT
ACTION- WE- WE ARE TRYING TO.
WADE INTO IT NEW SPACE HERE IN
AND SET PRECEDENTS THAT REALLY
HAVEN'T BEEN SET YET BUT- YOU
KNOW MY SENSE SO FAR IS THAT
THEY ARE SEEN AS SUCCESS. OKAY
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT- I'M
JUST. YOU KNOW I'M LOOKING HERE
AS ENVISIONED BY THE LEGISLATURE
THAT THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
INCLUDE DEVELOPING A STATEWIDE
CYBERSECURITY STRATEGY
OVERSEEING A CYBER INCIDENT
RESPONSE TEAM WHICH SERVICE
CALIFORNIA'S PRIMARY UNIT IN
CYBER THREAT DETECTION REPORTING
IN RESPONSE FOR THE PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE SECTORS ASSISTING LAW
ENFORCEMENT- FROM COLLECTING AND
SHARING CYBER THREAT INFORMATION
IT SEEMS LIKE. THEY HAVE ALREADY
BEEN TASKED WITH ESSENTIALLY
WHAT YOUR BILL- PROPOSES TO DO
THERE WE DON'T REALLY HAVE ANY
INFORMATION YET ARE DATA TO
SUGGEST THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
LARGELY SUCCESSFUL- IN THEIR
EFFORTS WELL I'M AS DEFINED IN
THE BEGINNING SO IT'S NOT THAT I
DON'T SUPPORT THE IDEA I'M JUST
. YOU KNOW KIND OF THINKING IN
MY HEAD THAT PERHAPS WE'RE
GIVING THEM MORE AND THEY SEEM
TO DO THE WHOLE POINT BEHIND
CREATING CAO CYSTIC WAS IT WAS
THIS. THINK TANK THAT- NEW
CERTAINLY MORE THAN THE MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE OF HOW TO
ADDRESS THIS. ISSUE AND LIKELY
WOULD. MAKE THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS YOU KNOW TO THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDLESS OF IF WE
MANDATE OR NOT MEAN THAT'S THE
WHOLE POINT OF THEIR EXISTENCE-
SEVEN THANK YOU FOR THE
INFORMATION. IF I MIGHT JUST
RESPOND JUST TO BE CLARIFIED
THAT WHAT CAL CYSTIC IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR IS CYBER
SECURITY PREVENTION I WHAT WE
ARE TRYING TO WITH THIS BILL IS
A SOME PARTICULAR CHANGES I IN
PRACTICE AROUND- THE CREDIT
REPORTING BUREAUS IN THE
RELATIONSHIP LENDERS WHICH
HOUSES IT DOES NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO- AND
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
CONTEMPLATING IS WHETHER IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE. TO HAVE MULTI
FACTOR AUTHENTICATION EVERY TIME
YOU HAVE AN ACCOUNT OPENED OUT
WHETHER WE SHOULD CREATE
ALTERNATIVES TO SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS. SO SCARY NUMBERS ARE
ALWAYS GOING TO BE ASSOCIATE
WITH ARDENT IDENTIFICATION. I'VE
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE TIED TO SO
MUCH ANCILLARY INFORMATION BUT
THE IDEA THAT YOUR SSN IS USED
AS YOUR PRIMARY POINT OF
AUTHORIZATION THAT IS TO SAY.
YOU GIVEN SSN. AND YOU HAVE
ACCESS TO OPENING UP FINANCIAL.
ACCOUNTS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
AYE DADDY SCENE IS VERY OUTDATED
THAT THIS NINE DIGIT NUMBER
SHOULD SERVE THAT PURPOSE. ALSO
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT WHAT WE SHOULD DO IS AN
ALTERNATIVE- THERE'S BEEN SOME
DEBATE AND SO WE HAVE THE CYBER
SECURITY- SELECT COMMITTEE
HEARING WHICH I CHAIR. RECENTLY
AND I THINK CENTER BOARD JUST
WAS PART OF THAT. AND I THINK
THIS SET CONSENSUS WAS THAT THE
NEED TO BE MORE STUDY BUT WHAT
THE BEST PRACTICES SHOULD BE SO.
THIS PARTICULAR STUDY IS VERY
FOCUSED. ON HOW WE CAN CREATE A
BERRIER STATE ANY THEFT AND
FINANCIAL FRAUD PARTICULAR NOT
CYBER SECURITY INCURSIONS BUT
HOW CAN PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM
THAT FIXING PROBLEM THAT IS
HITTING SO MANY OF US. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION. THE CIVIC
CENTER BACKER. YEAH I WOULD.
WHICH CAN THINK ON THEIR FOR HIS
WORK ON THIS BILL CERTAINLY
THESE THE CREDIT REPORTING
AGENCIES HAVE JUST VAST VAST
VAST AMOUNTS OF DATA AND LOOKING
AT WHAT WE CAN DO TO. MAKE SURE
IT'S PROTECTED I THINK IS VERY
VALUABLE AMOUNT DATABROKER BILL
THAT WILL- IF YOU TALK ABOUT
LATER BUT- I JUST APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORTS IN THIS AREA.
THANKS AND- GREAT- OKAY- SEARCH
WHAT AT THE BEGINNING DID YOU
MOVE THIS BILL YEAH THAT'S RIGHT
OKAY SO THE MOVEMENT BUILT IN
NEARBY CENTER ARCHULETA THE PAT
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED JUST
VERY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. HI DOT HI NIELSEN ALLEN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I'D BAKER.
BAKER I BORDERS REGIS I BRADFORD
GLAZER GLAZER IGHT WESO JONES
KAMLAGER MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AYE
PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO AYE WILK
. ELEVEN SEVEN VOTES PUT THAT
ITEM ON CALL- SO WE ALL. NOTED
SENATOR- THE S. B. TEN- FOR A
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE HAS- IN
WHICH WOULD DRAW ON. BUT THIS
POINT IN TIME. HM SUTTER
ARCHULETA WOULD YOU LIKE TO-
PRESENT. PLEASE PROCEED CENTER
ARCHULETA THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THIS MORNING I AM HERE
TO REPRESENT SENATE BILL ELEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH SEEKS TO
STRENGTHEN AND IMPROVE THE SMALL
BUSINESS AND DISABLED VETERANS
BENEFITS BUSINESS ENTERPRISE AND
THE PROGRAMS THEY'RE UP. SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WILL
INCREASE THE MAXIMUM CONTRACT
AMOUNT FOR SERVICES AND
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY CONTRACTS
AWARDED THROUGH THE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND DISABLED VETERANS
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE OPTION FROM
200-500-0025 HUNDRED THOUSAND.
THE SMALL BUSINESS DISABLED
VETERANS BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
CONTRACTING OPTION IS A
STREAMLINED PROCUREMENT.
ASSESSED FOR CERTIFIED SMALL
BUSINESSES MICRO BUSINESSES OR
DISABLED VETERAN'S BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES THE OPTION ALLOW
STATE DEPARTMENTS TO CONTRACT
DIRECTLY WITH CERTIFIED SMALL
BUSINESS DISABLED VETERANS
ENTERPRISE FOR GOODS SERVICES OR
I. T. AS LONG AS THE AGENCY ALSO
OBTAINS QUOTES FROM TWO SMALL
BUSINESS. VETERANS ENTERPRISES.
OTHER STATES SMALL AND VETERAN-
BUSINESSES HAVE FACED UNIQUE
CHALLENGES. IN OUR STATE IS NO
DIFFERENT OUR BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE THEY FACE ON OUR
VETERANS FACE UNIQUE CHALLENGES
THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC AND MANY
HAVE BEEN FORCED TO CLOSE OUR
DOORS AND OR LAY OFF STAFF. HIS
INCREASE TO THE SMALL BUSINESS
DISABLED VETERANS BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE OPTION IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE. BUSINESSES IN
THE STATE HAVE STRUGGLED WITH
INFLATION INCREASED EXPENSES
DRIVING UP THE COST OF GOODS AND
SERVICES AND NO DIFFERENT FROM
THE SMALL BUSINESSES. SENATE
BILL FORTY SEVENTY EIGHT
INCREASES THE MAXIMUM CONTRACT
AWARD FROM TO FOR A 200-500-0025
HUNDRED THOUSAND TO ALLOW SMALL
IN BETTER IS BUSINESS. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE COMPETITIVE
WHEN BIDDING FOR STATE CONTRACTS
WHILE ALSO INCREASING THE AMOUNT
THEY CAN BENEFIT FINANCIALLY
FROM BY DOING BUSINESS WITH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. INCREASING
THE OPTION TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WOULD HELP ADDRESS
RAISING COSTS AND INFLATION
WHILE ALSO. ENSURING THAT
THRESHOLD. IS APPROPRIATE FOR
pGOVERNMENT AGENCIES THAT AWARD
CONTRACTS FOR THE DEPARTMENTS
BUT TO IN FOR VETERANS. WITH
SMALL BUSINESSES AND VETERAN
OWNED COMPANIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
EQUITABLE RECOVERY REQUIRES
EMPHASIS ON THESE BUSINESS
GROUPS OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED THE
SERIES OF BILLS RECOMMENDED BY
THE STATE AUDITOR. TO IMPROVE
THIS AND STRENGTHEN THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROGRAM. IN
ADDITION TO THE LEGISLATION RE
REGARDING OVERSIGHT ADVOCATES
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS DISABLED
VETERANS BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY MET WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES.
AND ITS LEADERSHIP TO REQUEST
BETTER REPORTING IN THE PRIME
AND SUBCONTRACTOR UTILIZATION.
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES DEVELOP AN ANNUAL
REPORT THAT ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT TO IMPROVE THE
PROGRAM BY TRACKING REPORTING IN
PRIME AND SUBCONTRACT
UTILIZATION AND OBTAINING
CRUCIAL DATA. RIGHT TO THE
CREATION OF THE ANNUAL REPORT BY
SMALL BUSINESS DISABLED VETERANS
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE THERE WAS NO
WAY TO TRACK THE SUBCONTRACT
WORK. WE CAN NOW HAVE A CLEAR
AND ACCURATE PICTURE OF THE
SUCCESSES OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
DISABLED VETERANS BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE. AT THE PRIME AND
SUBPRIME LEVELS THESE VESTS FOR
EACH THESE EFFORTS WITH
ACCUMULATION OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN THE SMALL BUSINESS DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
COMMUNITY TO IMPROVE ON THE
PROGRAM. SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL HELP SUPPORT
LOCAL BUSINESSES DISABLED
VETERANS BUSINESS ON ENTERPRISE
IT WAS STRENGTHENING THE
PROGRAMS AND OUR LOCAL
ECONOMIES. ON THE LINE I HAVE-
BATTLING A SLIM- WITH TECHNOLOGY
ENTERPRISES IN INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATED OF CALIFORNIA- TED
FUENTES WITH ALLIANCE RESOURCES
GROUP WHO CAN ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS FOR THESE
REASONS AND MANY MORE. I
RESPECTFULLY AFTER I BROKE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF. SPEAKERS
WOULD YOU LIKE WHAT ONE YOU WERE
SAYING WITH TECHNICAL SUPPORT
THE FIRST WOMAN LIKE TO TESTIFY
YES IF THERE'S NOBODY IN THE
CHAMBERS AT THIS POINT TIME
ANYBODY ON THE LINE LIFE PLEASE
PROCEED. NOBODY ON THE LINE I
THINK BECAUSE OF OUR CHANGING
BUT- WITH THAT- LET ME GO AHEAD
AND GO UNDER THE COMMITTEE. AND
INDICATE THAT THIS IS A BIG STEP
FORWARD FOR OUR VETERANS- THEIR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND AYE URGENT
AYE VOTE. RIGHT PERFECT SO- WILL
NOW GO TO THE CALL LINE. SEE IF
THERE'S ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT MODERATOR. THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN GERALD TO SUPPORT SB.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. I'D GIVE
JUST A MOMENT HERE.
MODERATOR WE STILL WAITING. THE
WAIT HERE GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT
I CAN GO NOW TO THE LINE FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- BATTLING KLEIN ON
BEHALF OF TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA. TAXI
A WORK PRODUCT WORKING CO
SPONSOR. SB FORTY SEVENTY EIGHT
AND FIFTY FIVE AROUND EATING B.
BBEE PROGRAM. FOR INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESSIBILITY.
THANK. YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE GOT A LINE IF YOU WANT.
TWENTY NINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS JACK AND DALEM I SERVING
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS
VETERAN MAN ME ON A BLACK BOX
FIFTY DVD AND SANTIAGO I SUPPORT
SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
BECAUSE OF BENEFIT MY BUSINESS
AND ALL CRTIFIED SMALLING PVP
BUSINESSES AND EMPLOYEES CAN
STAY CALIFORNIA AMERICAN HE
WROTE YES. ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT IN LINE. FORTY FIVE. BOB GOOD MORNING
THIS IS TED POINT BOTH A MUSCLE
WITH VETERANS ON USA WERE
MANTRAS ARE PROVING A LOT OF THE
PATTERNS THROUGH- LEGISLATION-
SOME THE STATISTICS I WANTED TO
SHARE WITH YOUR CURRENTLY WE
HAVE 800-002-0090 FIVE CERTIFIED
BERMAN CALIFORNIA BROKEN DOWN AS
ONE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN DEFEATS
CERTIFICATION. SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY
THREE SMALL BUSINESS
CERTIFICATION THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE TWENTY NINE SMALL
BUSINESS ON. PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECT LOCATION THE AMOUNT OF
BLOOD THAT EXIST IN OUR OR OUR
PROGRAMS TO BE LOW POINT. ZERO
ZERO TWO SEVEN SIX I THINK THE
AND ON LAST RE YEAR- AT SENATOR
OR TO A MENTION. OF SOME OF US
THE NEED ETERNITY WORKOUT AND
WORKING WITH PANAMA WHAT. THAT
GAVE US A BETTER THAN A BILL.
FOR PRIVATE HOME. AND ALSO WE
WORK WITH PDF THROUGH CREATE
YEAH REPORT. AND WE JUST A
CERTAIN. AMOUNT OF FOR DATA. THE
SOME. REYES THE ARE OFF TO OF
HUNDRED- AND I. GROUPS THE BILL
- ONE THING I DO WANT BRING UP
IT IN THE PAST THEY'VE ONLY BEEN
ABLE TRACK- THE COST. SPEND NOW
THE TO THE REPORT WORK TO TRACK
BOTH D. V. R. D. V. D. E. PRIME
. AND SUB. SPEND SO I DON'T KNOW
EXAMPLE- WE HAD- I 200-019-2600
FIVE DB PRIME. IN FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY IZALCO. FOR AWARDED A
- AND I FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY. SIX HUNDRED THREE TV E.
PRIVATE CONTRA. AND FOR HOW
EIGHT EDB SUB. OR WILL WORK SO
FEDERAL A LOT OF. WE NOW THE TO
THEY WAIT THE DATA AND- THAT
SHOW THAT IT'S WORK OUT APPLE.
THE STATE DID YOU. HAVE MET
DEEPLY EVOLVED A LETTER IN THE-
IN A ROW I'M SO TWELVE GOING TO
LOVE. AGAIN I URGE ALL OF YOU
YOUR VOTE YES ON FOUR. FEB EIGHT
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR CAR THANK
YOU OR FOR ALLOWING THE CO
SPONSOR THIS THANK YOU. AND THEN
FURTHER IN Q. A THIS TIME. THANK
YOU HAVING- HEARD FROM SUPPORT
AND DON'T. IN OP. UP IN THE
CHAIN- WILL MOVE OUT TO THE TELE
ARE MODEL. IF YOU'D PLEASE PROP
TO WAITING TO. IN OPPOSITION
DESK THE FOURTEENTH EIGHT. AND
IF SO PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
IT WAS JUST A MOMENT HERE. THE
LINE FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CARE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS PHIL VERMAELEN I REPRESENT
THE COALITION A SMALL A DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESSES- I ALSO SERVE
ON THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES SMALL BUSINESS ADVISORY
TASK FORCE FOR THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS AND LAST YEAR WAS CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMERCIALLY USEFUL
FUNCTION COMMITTEE- ONE OF THE
BIG PROBLEMS WITH THE SMALL
BUSINESS IS THERE ARE MANY LARGE
BUSINESSES THAT WILL GO IN THE
AN OFFER A SMALL BUSINESSES 82%
SPIFF AS WE CALL IT. TO ALLOW
THEM TO UTILIZE THE SMALL
BUSINESS TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THOSE SMALL
BUSINESS- IT PROGRAMS THE
PROBLEM IS WE'RE TALKING YOU
HAVE TO CLARIFY THERE IS WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY
AND THAT IS THE TO CALL SYSTEM
SO FOR EXAMPLE UP TO TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS DGS NOW
FROM THERE BUYERS CAN CALL TO
PEOPLE THAT ARE CERTIFIED SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESSES. AND OBTAIN A PRICE
FROM THEM THAT'S ALL GREAT AND
WONDERFUL- THEY WERE BEEN FOR
DIFFERENT TIMES. THIS BILL HAS
BEEN. BUT THROUGH THE LEAD. WE
HAVE BEEN ACT. OPPOSED THE WHOLE
TIME IT'S COUNTER TO THE BY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT AND THINK
WELL GEEZ WE'RE GONNA RAISE AT
THE FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS. REMEMBER FOR FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE TO RAISE THOSE
KINDS OF FUNDS FROM. BANK ALONE
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE OUT THAT LOAN
TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
PRODUCT. OF A LOT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES CARE IF YOU LOOK AT
THE NUMBERS. ON THE AUDIENCE
OVERLAP NUMEROUS YEARS OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS THERE ARE A
HANDFUL OF BUSINESSES THAT ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THESE
PROGRAMS THE BASS MAJORITY AT
THE BP AND SMALL BUSINESSES. ARE
NOT GETTING THE BENEFITS FROM
THE REYES FROM TO AT UP TO TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY IF YOU MAKE IT UP
TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND THAT
AGAIN IS GOING TO BENEFIT SOME
PEOPLE THERE ARE NUMEROUS THINGS
WE CAN DO WE NEED TO TIGHTEN THE
LAWS FOR EXAMPLE- ONE OF THE
PROBLEM. THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES DID AWAY WITH
WHAT WE CALL CONTRACTS ONE OF
MYERS SEVERAL OF MY MEMBERS A
COUPLE YEARS AGO LOST OVER A
MILLION DOLLARS ON A CONTRACT
WITH THE STATE. WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY CONTRACTED WITH THE
STATE TO PROVIDE PRODUCTS THEY
HAVE TO ORDER THOSE PRODUCTS.
AND AT THEIR OWN EXPENSE AND
THEN GIVE YOU A MAP OVER THE
YEAR THE CONTRACT UNFORTUNATELY
THE STATE HAS THE RIGHT NOW. TO
ELIMINATE THOSE CONTRACTS IF FOR
WHATEVER REASON THINGS CHANGE SO
THEY'RE NOT REALLY CONTRACT A
ONE PLANET GREEN. THAT IT BURNS
SMALL BUSINESSES THAT IS
SOMETHING WE NEED TO CLARIFY WE
NEED TO GET THAT RESOLVED
BECAUSE THAT ALMOST RATES OF ALL
MY BILLS. MY MEMBERS OUT OF
BUSINESS BUT BY RAISING A FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS THERE
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY NO CONTROL
OVER THOSE. BUYERS IN TERMS OF
WHO THE TWO PEOPLE THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GO OUT AND REACH OUT TO
YOU. AND THAT CONSEQUENTLY IS
WHY IF YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS-
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO A VAST
MAJORITY OF US BY THE HANDFUL.
OF BUSINESS IS NOT TO. ASKED ME
TO OF PEOPLE IT SHOULD BE OUT
THERE WITH ARE SMALL BUSINESS
HELLO THREE I PLEDGE TO WORK THE
SENATE ON COMING UP WITH SOME
THAT WILL WORK BUT INCREASE THE
LIMIT OF FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IS JUST GOING TO PROMOTE MORE
FRAUD SO FOR THOSE REASONS
UNFORTUNATELY WE OPPOSE THE BILL
AS IT. CURRENTLY READS THANK YOU
. I THANK YOU MISTER JIM
VERMILION WHEN HE SAID WE- IT
YOU REPRESENTING A- UTAH'S WHAT
WHAT WERE YOU WHICH IS A SMALL
AND DISABLED. OKAY SO THE
COALITION IS SMALL AND STABLE
VETERAN BUSINESSES I THANK YOU I
AM A LOTTERY OR ANYBODY ELSE
WISHING TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE
. NOT AT THIS POINT OKAY SO WE
ARE GOING TO BRING THIS BACK TO
OUR MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS- I'M NOT SEEN ANYBODY
I'D SERIOUS- CONCERN HERE- SAID
ARCHULETA. DO YOU WANT TO
ADDRESS THAT IN YOUR CLOTHES YES
PLEASE PROCEED YES ONCE AGAIN
AND I'LL BRING IN THE EXPERT
THAT  BROUGHT IN BUT ONCE AGAIN
HERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
VETERANS- TO COME TOGETHER TO
START OPENING UP THEIR BUSINESS
TO BE COMPETITIVE AND IN TODAY'S
WORLD TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
IS AS A SMALL SMALL AMOUNT. AND
IS SO NOW THEY'LL BE ABLE TO BE
COMPETITIVE IN REACH UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND UP TO NOT
NECESSARILY THE FIVE AND THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THE BUSINESSES
THAT YOU'VE HEARD ARE ARE WITH
US THE OTHER THE THING THAT WAS
MENTIONED BUT FRAUD IT'S A
MINUTE MIGHT MUTE- AMOUNT IN
BECAUSE OF THE- THE OVERSIGHT
THAT'S THERE- WE ARE IN GOOD
SHAPE AND I THINK THAT THIS
BILL. AS THE LAST ONE WILL OPEN
DOORS FOR ME MORE AND MORE
VETERANS INVOLVED BUSINESSES AND
SO WITH THAT AYE RICHER AYE
VOTE. OKAY ANYBODY- ANY MEMBERS
WISHING TO- MOVE THIS BILL.
SUTTER GLAZER THANK YOU THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO MILITARY
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE. A
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
DODD I THOUGHT I'D NIELSEN ALLEN
ARCHULETA AYE ARCHULETA AYE
BAKER. BAKER HI GORGEOUS
BRADFORD GLAZER GLAZER HI WESO
JONES KAMLAGER MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
I PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO I WILL
. SIX ZERO TERMINAL CALL A BILLS
ARE CALL CENTER WIENER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR- PATIENTS
THANK YOU MR THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA. SO WE'RE MOVING NOW
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX S. B.
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR I CENTER
WIENER CENTER YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU TO YOU IN THE
COMMITTEE. OUR COLLEAGUES THAT
I'M PRESENTING SENATE BILL
ELEVEN FORTY FOR THE SAFE AND
EFFICIENT WATER ACT. WE KNOW
THAT CALIFORNIA IS A LEADING
EXAMPLE FOR THE NATION AND
WORLD- WITH SO MANY OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND HEALTH AND
SAFETY POLICIES. HOWEVER
TRAGICALLY OUR DRINKING WATER
REGULATIONS DO NOT ALWAYS PASS
MUSTER. I KNOW WHERE IS THIS
MORE EVIDENT THAN IN OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS DATA COLLECTED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY- SHOW
THAT 53% OF REPORTING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FOUND LEAD IN AT LEAST
ONE OF THEIR DRINKING WATER
FOUND. GUNS ON CAMPUS. LET OF
COURSE IS INCREDIBLY DANGEROUS
FOR EVERYONE PARTICULARLY
CHILDREN. I'M AFRAID IN TWENTY
ONE HUNDRED DRINKING WATER
FOUNTAINS TESTED POSITIVE FOR
LEAD IN THIRTEEN HUNDRED SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA. UNFORTUNATELY
THIS ISSUE- DOESN'T STOP WITH
LET THE SAME WATER SYSTEMS I MAY
HAVE BEEN EXPOSING STUDENTS TO
LEASE AN HOUR RATE ON AN ARM AND
A HOST OF OTHER POTENTIALLY
HARMFUL CONTAMINANTS. I HOWEVER
THE TESTING THE BROUGHT- THE
DATA AROUND LED TO LIGHT DID NOT
REQUIRE TESTING FOR ANY OF THESE
OTHER CONTAMINANTS. WITHOUT A
TESTING REGIME STATE WILL
CONTINUE TO OPERATE- IN
DARKNESS- ASSUMING THAT SCHOOLS
AND STATE AGENCIES ARE FOR
FILLING EVERY CALIFORNIANS RIGHT
TO CLEAN AND SAFE WATER WHEN
THAT ASSUMPTION TRAGICALLY IS
NOT WARRANTED NOT AND- NOT
BECAUSE OF INTENTIONAL HARM- BUT
BECAUSE WE'RE SIMPLY NOT DOING
INSPECTIONS. SB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR WILL REMEDY THE SITUATION
BY REQUIRING ALL PUBLIC SCHOOLS
AS WELL AS STATE AGENCIES FOR
STATE OWNED BUILDINGS TO
COMPLETE A WATER QUALITY
ASSESSMENT ON THEIR FACILITIES.
INCLUDING TESTING PER LED RATE
ON A LEGIONELLA AND OTHER
CONTAMINANTS IF THEY FIND A
CONTAMINANT THE OPERATING AGENCY
WILL BE REQUIRED TO REPLACE THE
FIXTURE AT THE EARLIEST
PRACTICAL TIME SUBJECT TO
FUNDING- AND ALSO. TO PROVIDE
NOTIFICATIONS SO PEOPLE KNOW
THAT THEIR IS AN ISSUE- IF. DAY
FUNDS IS NOT A- IN. IS NOT KERR
POSSIBLE- THE OPERATING- AGENCY
WILL BE REQUIRED TO PREPARE
WATER QUALITY MANAGEMENT PLAN.
TO INCLUDE INTERIM REMEDIATION
MEASURES AS WELL AS REGULAR
TESTING. ON A MAJOR REASON FOR
CONTAMINATION OF SCHOOLS AND
STATE AGENCIES IS THE AGE OF
BUILDINGS OLDER PLUMBING SYSTEMS
ARE OFTEN MORE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
POTENTIAL CONTAMINATION. AND ARE
MORE LIKELY TO CONTAIN SOME.
ASPECT OF LEAD FROM THE PIPES
ADDITIONALLY THESE OLD SYSTEMS
ARE LIKELY TO BE INEFFICIENT
EITHER BY LEAKING AND WASTING. A
LARGE AMOUNT OF WATER- OR BY
SIMPLY BEING AN EFFICIENT AND
UTILIZING EXCESSIVE AMOUNTS. OF
WATER SB ONE FORTY FOUR WILL
ADDITIONALLY REQUIRE SCHOOLS AND
STATE AGENCIES TO TEST THEIR
WATER EFFICIENCY- AND SUBJECT TO
FUNDING. OF REPLACE FIXTURES OR
APPLIANCES THAT DON'T MEET WATER
EFFICIENCY STANDARDS. FINALLY
THE BILL WILL REQUIRE SCHOOLS
AND STATE AGENCIES. TO DETERMINE
THE FEASIBILITY OF INSTALLING AN
ONSITE GREYWATER SYSTEM WE KNOW
THAT WATER RECYCLING AS PART OF.
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE- WE ARE
WORKING CURRENTLY ON AMENDMENTS
WITH- WHATEVER USE- REGARDING
THIS- GRAY WATER PROVISION TO
BROADEN AT- AND ALLOW CONNECTION
TO ALTERNATIVE RECYCLED WATER
SYSTEMS. RATHER THAN EXCLUSIVELY
OUR GRAY WATER- SO WE- OUR
INTENT IS TO INCORPORATE- THOSE
MOMENTS IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE IF
THE COMMITTEE PASSES THE BILL
TODAY- THIS TESTING. BOTH OF
POTENTIAL CONTAMINATION IN WATER%
QUALITY AND EFFICIENCY ACROSS
BUILDINGS THAT HOUSE OR USE
PUBLIC SERVANTS AND A HOST OF
OTHER CALIFORNIANS WILL ENSURE
THAT THE STATE IS PROTECTING THE
RIGHT TO CLEAN SAFE WATER. AND
IS CONSERVING THIS PRECIOUS
RESOURCE- COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ARE WELL WITH ME TODAY TO
TESTIFY. OR SCOTT WHAT'S ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPONSORED THE
STATE PIPES. COUNCIL AS WELL AS
THOMAS AND ON THE OF THE- SO. OF
PLUMBING AND THE KIND OF
OFFICIALS. MORNING MR WEBB'S
PLEASE PROCEED. MISTER CHAIRMAN
A MEMBER SCOTT WENT SHOULD BE
HALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARK
TRADES COUNCIL THE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL REPRESENTS LOCAL
PLUMBING INSPECTORS IN
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA WHOSE JOB IT IS TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND
SAFETY IN DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS
. UNFORTUNATELY CORRODING PIPES-
PROVIDING THE IDEAL NUTRIENTS
FOR BACTERIA TO GROW AS A RESULT
ACCORDING TO THE CASE THE CDC.
THE NUMBER OF. SICKNESS IS BEING
REPORTED EACH YEAR AS A RESULT
OF MICRO ORGANISMS IN OUR
DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS NOW
APPROACHES NEARLY THIRTY TWO
MILLION. PARTICULARLY OF CONCERN
IS THE DRAMATIC RISE IN THE
CASES OF LEGIONELLA THAT HAVE
BEEN REPORTED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND. IN THE LAST YEAR
AVAILABLE THAT THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT'S REPORTED OVER TEN
THOUSAND CASES OF LEGIONELLA IN
THE UNITED STATES. YOU MAY NOT
BE AWARE BUT 10% OF VICTIMS WHO
FALL ILL WITH LEGIONELLA
ACTUALLY DYING. JUST LAST WEEK
WE HAD A LEGIONELLA OUTBREAK AT
A HOTEL IN HAWAII. SB ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR ATTEMPTS TO GET- THE
STATE'S ARMS AROUND THIS. BY
THIS PROBLEM BY A MODEST BUT
TESTING OF OUR WATER SYSTEM AND
REQUIRING THE BUILDING OWNERS
PUT TOGETHER A MANAGEMENT PLAN
TO ADDRESS ANY- PROBLEMS WITH
LEAD IN PIPE OR WITH OTHER
MICROORGANISMS- WE WOULD URGE AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER WAX NECKS BAKER. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS COMMENTS
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF PLUMBING AND
MECHANICAL OFFICIALS OR AT I AM
ALL I AM WITH THE PUBLISHER OF
THE- MODEL OP TIMING CODE THAT
CALIFORNIA PLUMBING CODE IS
BASED ON AND ALSO HAS. WATER
QUALITY- DIVISIONS AS WELL. WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL I JUST LIKE TO
MAKE A COUPLE- ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS ON IT ONE ON THE
EFFICIENCY ISSUE- THERE WAS
LEGISLATION A NUMBER YEARS AGO
THAT REQUIRED COMMERCIAL AND
RESIDENTIAL BUILDINGS TO UPDATE
UPDATE AND REPLACE OLD
INEFFICIENT PLUMBING FIXTURES.
BUT IT DIDN'T APPLY TO PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND STATE BUILDINGS-
REPLACING THESE INEFFICIENT
PICTURES WOULD SAVE BILLIONS OF
GALLONS OF WATER A YEAR AS WELL
AS- REPLACE OLDER PICTURES THAT
HAVE A HIGHER MY CONTENT. THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD. REQUIRE
SCHOOLS AND STATE BUILDINGS TO
IDENTIFY WHETHER THEY HAVE AN
EFFICIENT FIXTURES TO REPLACE IT
IF FUNDING IS AVAILABLE AND WE
DO KNOW FUNDING IS AVAILABLE
SUCH AS AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
CALLOUS A PLUMBING PROGRAM
INCENTIVES THE LEGISLATURE
PASSED. A COUPLE YEARS AGO AND
THE NEW FEDERAL OF BUILDING
BETTER SCHOOL. INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM THAT'S COMING DOWN THE
LINE. THE ALSO REQUIRES A
CERTAIN WATER POLO AND- AS A I
MISS WEST DISK THIS IS A RELEASE
WITH. RATE ON WE- LEGION IS
LEADING CAUSE OF- OF SICKNESS
AND BUILDINGS. ARE THIS WOULD
REQUIRE THEM TO IDENTIFY WHETHER
THESE ISSUES TO REMEDIATE THEM
WITHIN A YEAR OR TO HAVE A
MANAGEMENT PLAN IF YOU CAN'T
REMEDIATE INTERMEDIATE IT WITHIN
A YEAR. IT WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
THE COOLING TOWERS HAVE
LEGIONELLA MANAGEMENT PLAN IN
PLACE WHICH IS THE INDUSTRY.
MOST BUILDINGS ARE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH THAT YOU KNOW THE GENERAL
INDUSTRY STANDARD. AND THEN
FINALLY MYERS- NO SCHOOLS TO
ENSURE THAT YOU KNOW THOSE THAT
IF THEY DO HAVE WATER QUALITY
THAT AT RISK FOR STUDENTS OR
STATE- WORKERS THAT THEY ARE
PROVIDE NOTICE OF IT AND WE
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT WAY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE STUFF GOOD
STUFF I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. EXPECT HER. MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. I CAN JUST
WEST. SO LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD- PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN FORTY FOUR. THANK
YOU TO SUPPORT SB ELEVEN FORTY
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND IF
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
GET IT ONE ZERO. ONE MOMENT. AND
CURRENTLY NINETY Q. THANK YOU- I
DON'T SEE ANYBODY HERE IN
OPPOSITION IN THE CHAMBERS CAN
WE DO THE SAME THING MODERATOR
ON THE LINE TO PROP ANYBODY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
. OF THIS THANK YOU SB ALONG THE
FORTY FOUR SURE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR RIDE TO AVOID SB ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. CURRENTLY NINETY
Q. THANK YOU- MODERATOR THAT
WILL MOVE IT BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
HERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
CENTER ARCHULETA YES- SURE THANK
YOU- FOR THE EXPERTS ON THE
LINE- THE CONTAMINATION OF THE
LEAD BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING I'M
TO GIVE THE SCHOOLS IS IT THE
WATER FOUNTAIN RIGHT AT THAT
AREA WHERE THE WATER IS THERE
AND COMES OUT AND AT THAT POINT
IT'S CONTAMINATED AND YOU
DISCOVER THE LEAD OR SAID IN THE
BEGINNING AS THE WATER COMES IN.
TO THE SCHOOL AND- ALONG THE-
THE PIPES AND SO ON I'M JUST
THINKING IS IT THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT- REPAIRING ALL THE
WATER FOUNTAINS WITH NEW PIPING
AND SO ON ARE WE LOOKING AT
RETYPING THE PARTICULAR SCHOOL
FROM ONE END TO THE OTHER CENTER
WHAT WHAT DID YOU FIND IN ON
THAT YEAH I SURE CAN ANSWER THAT
IF MR WATCH THANK YOU NOT ONLY
CAN THE ON THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT THE WATER FOUNTAIN ITSELF
I MEAN IT'S ABOUT- THE ENTIRE
PLUMBING SYSTEM POTENTIALLY-
EVALUATING IT BECAUSE EVEN IF
THE- EVEN IF THE WATER FOUND
ITSELF IS OKAY THERE MIGHT BE A
DEEPER. PROBLEM AND OF COURSE
WATER ALSO COMES OUT OF SYNCS
AND OTHER AREAS ARE I THE
KITCHENS WHERE THEY'RE MAKING
FOOD FOR THE KIDS- BUT PERHAPS
MISTER WATCH COULD. OUT ON TO
THE- THIS FOR WHAT YOU HAVE
ANYTHING THE- ON THE- HE- YES
MISTER CHAIRMAN. THE AS CENTER
FOR OUT THE BILL DOESN'T. READ
UNLESS THERE'S FUND OF A IN THE-
MAY THE- BONTA THAT LEADS PASSED
PUT ON THE BACK TO YOUR AGO.
THERE IS A LITTLE UNDER TWO
BILLION DOLLARS SET ASIDE JUST
FOR LEAD REMEDIATION IN SCHOOLS
SO THIS. YOU KNOW THIS WILL ONLY
REQUIRE THAT TYPE OF WORK IF THE
FUNDING WAS AVAILABLE. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
ANYBODY ELSE CENTER BACKER. WE
HAVE A MOTION FROM CENTER BACKER
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO ADDRESS
THE THIS BILL SEEING NONE. SO
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
BAKER- WOULD YOU LIKE THIS IS A
DO PASSED EDUCATION- CENTER
WIENER WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IRA. SO
WITH THAT IS TO DO PASSED
EDUCATION COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. DODD I
THOUGHT. NIELSEN ALLEN
ARCHULETA. ARCHULETA ALL RIGHT
BAKER BAKER FIVE LARGEST
BRADFORD GLAZER GLAZER IGHT WESO
JONES KAMLAGER MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
I PORTANTINO RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
WELL. SIX ZERO TERMINAL CALL.
THAT'S THE SIX VOTES THE BILL
WAS ON CALL AND WE ARE WAITING
NOW I THINK FOR SENATOR MORE-
LEÓN I'M GONNA MOVE FOR IT A
QUICK RECESS UNTIL SHE APPEARS.
THE COMMITTEE- RETURNS FROM
SHORT RECESS. WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE ON TO. FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVERAL MON YOU MAYBE GET THANK
YOU TURN MEMBERS SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN ESTABLISHES A
WORKING GROUP TO DISCUSS AND
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ON WAYS TO
ENSURE BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF THE
STATE THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES BY
DECEMBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. IT
REPORT WITH AGGREGATE
DEMOGRAPHIC INFORMATION OF
INDIVIDUALS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR TO ENSURE CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP IS REFLECTIVE OF ITS
GREATER POPULATION IT'S THE
COLLECTION OF GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTEE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IS A
CRITICAL STEP TO ACHIEVE AND
MAINTAIN GENDER RACIAL AND
ETHNIC EQUITY ON BOARDS AND
COMMISSIONS. THE ANNUAL REPORT
WILL SERVE AS A TOOL TO IDENTIFY
GAPS IN REPRESENTATION ENCOURAGE
OUTREACH TO COMMUNITIES AND
ADDRESS BARRIERS TO SEEKING AN
APPOINTMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- YOU HAVE IT IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. CORRECT ON THE LINE
PLEASE BEGIN I BELIEVE IT'S-
MISS TAURUS. YES HELLO AND HI
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN DIED IN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND NINETEEN
MY NAME IS HELEN TORRANCE FIND
CEO AND DIRECTOR OF THE PLANET
ORGANIZED POLITICALLY QUALITY
HELLO. THE NONPROFIT NONPARTISAN
ORGANIZATION COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THE POLITICAL AND
ECONOMIC SECURITY OF PLUCKING AT
LEADERSHIP ADVOCACY AND
EDUCATION TO BENEFIT ALL
COMMUNITIES AND THE STATUS OF
WOMEN. PERFECT PROUD TO BE ONE
OF THE SPONSORS THAT ACT THE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN AND WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO BE WORKING WITH
SENATOR LIMON ON THIS IMPORTANT
TOPIC. SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
SIXTY GREAT TRANSPARENCY AND OF
THE TORAH. APPOINTMENT I READ AN
ANNUAL REPORT BE REALLY JANET
DEMOCRATS DATA ABOUT ALL OF.
MADE THE PREVIOUS YEAR. THIS
REPORT WHAT IT INCLUDE IN OF A
THE SUCH AS GENDER ETHNICITY A
BILL STAFF. SPECIAL OR- ACTION
STATUS AND REGION. UP THIS AND
REPORT WILL HELP. THE PUB
UNDERSTAND THAT THE COMPANY OF
THE- IT ENACTED THE DATA WILL BE
A TWO TO WHERE THERE'S C. AND
WRAPPED. LACKING AND WHAT.
INVOICE I'M AND PAPER. AND IT IS
TO THE N. REPORT SB THIRTY EIGHT
A QUICK APPETITE LIMITED FOR
GROUP THAT IS TASKED WITH THAT.
BURIED EFFORT THE FIND. THIS
CASE BY JUNE AND DO NOT WILL NOT
HOLD ANY OF. AND MAKING. HOWEVER
WILL TO. THEIR DEEP UNDER OF
COMMUNITY. EIGHT OKAY MADE
COMMITTED TO ENSURING THAT
HEALTH. HEALTH WHEN SEVEN CHILE
BY. OF THE RICH DIVERSITY AT THE
STATE IT ISN'T TO NOTE RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT. IN NEED TO. THAT ARE
BETTER. OF THE INTEREST OF THOSE
RAW. AND AS THE MOST POP AND
DIVERSE IN THE- WE BELIEVE
CALIFORNIA LEAD MORE. WE BELIEVE
IT'S TO TELL TO FOR MAKING. TO
ENSURE A IT SUB TO REFLECT THE
COMMUNITIES BEING THERE AND
BELIEVE THE MARKET IS STRONG
WHEN IT THAT THE TABLE. THIRTY
REASONS I TO ASK FOR YOUR THE
TODAY THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
- TO THE MODERATE KIM PLEASE
PROP UPIN THE- WAIT TO TEST IN
SOME. OF THIRTY EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE. TURNING INTO SUPPORT
THIRTY EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. WE CAN FIRST
CAROLINE. THIRTY ONE. GOOD
MORNING KATRINA RENDON BEHALF OF
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLOR OF.
INSTRUCT AT SPEED EIGHTY THE YOU
. MAKE IT'S ONE ZERO. AND THEN
FURTHER AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU ARE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION- THERE'S NONE IN
THE CHAMBER MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE PROP WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WAITING TO TESTIFY IF
ANY. THANK YOU AGAIN TO OPPOSE
THIS ONE ZERO. AND CURRENTLY
NINETY Q. OKAY THANK YOU- WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBERS SENATOR GLAZERS.
THANK YOU AT YOUR DIED AYE AYE
RISES A STRONG SUPPORTER OF THIS
LEGISLATION- THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE PAST SAID THAT. TAKING
ACTION TO TRY TO- PROMOTE.
ESTABLISH DIVERSITY AND PRIVATE
BOARDS AROUND OUR STATE WHICH
HAS COME UNDER CONSTITUTIONAL
CHALLENGE NOT UNEXPECTEDLY. BUT
THIS IS A AN EXAMPLE OF- OF
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS THAT WE
CONTROL AND I THINK THAT THE-
THE PURPOSES- AS OUTLINED IN THE
BILL ARE MERITORIOUS. AND WORTHY
I DON'T THINK THE AUTHOR AND I
CERTAINLY DOUBT MYSELF INCLUDED
DON'T FEEL THAT OUR CURRENT
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR BROWN BEFORE
HIM- THEY'VE DONE A GREAT JOB
OF- ADVANCING DIVERSITY AND
THEIR APPOINTMENTS AND I DON'T
SEE THIS NECESSARILY IS ANY KIND
OF CRITICISM- BUT IT'S- IT'S
TRYING TO GATHER THE FACTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT. IF THERE WAYS
THAT WE CAN DO BETTER- WE
CERTAINLY DO SO WITH THAT
THERE'S OPPORTUNITY DOWN THE
LINE FOR THE AUTHOR TO ACCEPT CO
AUTHORS I'D BE VERY INTERESTED
IN JOINING AND THAT WITH THAT
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE ABILITY FOR
PRE TIME. GREAT THANK YOU-
SEEING NOBODY ELSE WITH MIKE'S
UP. WE HAVE A- MOTION BY-
SENATOR GLAZER BUT BEFORE WE
TAKE THAT BOAT- CENTER LIMÓN
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE. THANK YOU
AND I ABSOLUTELY WILL WELCOME CO
AUTHORS AND ALSO THE COMMENT
THAT THIS IS NOT A REFLECTION OR
CRITICISM WE'RE ACTUALLY TRYING
TO FIND A WAY TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE BEST PRACTICES.
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
MEANINGFUL GAMES IN TERMS OF
DIVERSIFYING OUR MANY MANY
BOARDS IN THE STATE AND THIS IS
A WAY TO TRY TO ALLOW US. TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE SOME OF THESE
GAMES AND I ALSO WANT TO KNOW
THAT THE GAMES ARE NOT JUST
BASED ON RACE AND ETHNICITY AND
GENDER THEY'RE ALSO GEOGRAPHIC.
AYE WE REPRESENT FIFTY DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AND SO FOR US IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE KEEP AND MAINTAIN THAT
DIVERSITY- THAT WE'VE SEEN.
INCREASING OVER THE LAST YEARS
AND SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR- GLAZER FOR THOSE. THOSE
COMMENTS AND- THAT CLOSE BECAUSE
I THINK IT BRINGS GREATER
GREATER CLARITY TO THIS BILL. SO
THE SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. YES IS FILE ITEM
ELEVEN SB THIRTY MASS TO
JUDICIARY YES TO PASSAGE ISHERI
DOT. BY DOT I NIELSEN. ALLEN.
OUR DATA. JULY I'D BETTER. THANK
HI GORGEOUS BRADFORD PLAYED
GLAZER AYE WESO JOE KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER HI MELENDEZ MELENDEZ NO
POINT RUBIO. RUBIO I WILL. SIXTY
ONE SHERMAN ON CALL. THE BILL IS
ON CALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENDING EMAIL. OKAY NOW WILL
MOVE YOUR LAST ITEM TODAY FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE SB 1275% MORE
SENATOR COM AUGER. SENATOR CALM
WATER YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I THINK IT'S
STILL A GOOD MORNING TO EVERYONE
. YES THAT'S ELEVEN O'CLOCK SO
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
I'M HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ON SB
TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE STAFFER THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION THAT WE HAVE HAD ON
THIS BILL. SB TWELVE SEVENTY
FIVE LEE SAYS THAT IF YOU ARE A
CALIFORNIANS AND YOU HAVE BILLS
TO PAY TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT YOU CAN NOTE
THAT YOU MUST BUT THAT YOU CAN
USE VIRTUAL CURRENCY TO DO SO IF
THE STATE AGENCY WILL ALLOW IT.
SB TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE IS A
PERMISSIVE BILL THAT WOULD NOT
REQUIRE A STATE AGENCY TO ACCEPT
VIRTUAL. WHAT IT WOULD DO IS PUT
CALIFORNIA IN THE GAME ON AN
ISSUE WHERE WE HAVE BEEN SORELY
LACKING. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THIRTY THREE STATES AUTHORED
LEGISLATION ON VIRTUAL CURRENCY
AND HOW TO USE IT EXCEPT IT
VALUE IT RECORD IT. AND REALLY
JUST HOW TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT IT
EXISTS. IN CALIFORNIA WAS NOT
ONE OF THOSE STATES AND SO HERE
WE ARE IN TWENTY TWO. VIRTUAL
CURRENCY IS HERE TO STAY AND
WHILE IT MAY NOT BE INGRAINED IN
DAILY LIFE. OR UBIQUITOUS IN THE
FINANCIAL ECOSYSTEM OR EVEN A
PROMINENT PART F AN INVESTMENT
PORTFOLIO IS ON TRACK TO BE ALL
OF THOSE THINGS AND MORE IN THE
VERY NEAR FUTURE. WE SHOULD NOT
BE AFRAID OF VIRTUAL CURRENCY WE
SHOULD BE EMBRACING IT. BECAUSE
IT IS MONEY. IT IS JUST MONEY
THAT IS STORED OR EXCHANGED
USING COMPUTER SYSTEMS. THE ROLE
OF PHYSICAL CASH IS DECLINING
ACROSS THE GLOBE AS INSTITUTIONS
ADOPT NEW TECHNOLOGIES. AND
VIRTUAL CURRENCY HAS ARRIVED AND
INDIVIDUALS AND COMPANIES ARE
ADOPTING IT. WHILE STOCK MARKET
INVESTORS ARE GENERALLY WHITE
MAN 44% OF BITCOIN AND CRYPTO
INVESTORS ARE NON WHITE SURVEY
SHOWS THAT 16% OF AMERICANS HAVE
INVESTED IN DIGITAL CURRENCY AND
ACCORDING TO DATA FROM HARRIS
POLL GIVEN EXCLUSIVELY TO USA
TODAY 23% OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
IN SEVENTEEN PERCENT. OF
HISPANIC AMERICANS OWN VIRTUAL
ASSETS WHICH IS JUST ABOUT
INVESTING NOT ABOUT PAYMENTS IT
IS CLEAR THAT BANKING
INSTITUTIONS ARE ALSO INVESTING
A LOT OF THEIR RESEARCH RESEARCH
RESOURCES AND RESEARCH REGARDING
CRYPTOCURRENCY INTEGRATION IN
THEIR OPERATIONS. VISA HAS
STARTED A CRYPTO CONSULTING
SERVICE AND INVESTED IN CRYPTO
PLATFORMS AS PART OF A PUSH FOR
DIGITAL CURRENCY ADOPTION APPLE
PAY AND GOOGLE PAY MAKE IT EVEN
EASIER TO SPEND VIRTUAL CURRENCY
CHASE AND BANK OF AMERICA ARE
INVESTING HEAVILY IN THIS SPACE
IN ORDER TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
WAVE OF TRANSACTIONS THAT ARE
COMING. MANY OF WHICH THEY ARE
ALREADY MISSING OUT ON. SB
TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE ACCEPTANCE
OF VIRTUAL CURRENCY MAKES SENSE
FOR STATE AGENCIES FOR THE SAME
REASONS THAT MAKES SENSE FOR
BUSINESSES THE EASE OF PAYMENT
BY THE CONSUMER. AND REDUCED
COSTS OF PAYMENT PROCESSING BY
THE SERVICE AGENCY. VIRTUAL
CURRENCY CAN BE USED AS A TOOL
FOR SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE
ONE THAT CAN HELP UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES INCREASE OUR
ECONOMIC MOBILITY BY BUILDING
GENERATIONAL WEALTH. ACCORDING
TO THE FINANCIAL HEALTH NETWORK
UNBANKED AND UNDERBANKED
AMERICANS SPEND A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY NINE BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEES AND INTEREST ON FINANCIAL
PRODUCTS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
LATEST YEAR FOR WHICH THERE IS
COMPLETE DATA. USING THE FDIC'S
ESTIMATE THAT SOME SIXTY THREE
MILLION AMERICANS ARE UNBANKED
OR UNDERBANKED THAT WOULD BE AN
AVERAGE OF THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL COSTS PER
PERSON THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE TO
BEAR. MANY PEOPLE HAVE RAISED
CONCERNS ABOUT SECURITY AND
HACKING AND BAD ACTORS AND I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE SOME OF
THAT. IN MY OPENING HEY THERE
ARE CONCERNS CONCERN SECURITY
CONCERNS HACKING AND BAD ACTORS
IN THE TRADITIONAL FINANCIAL
LENDING SPACES RIGHT NOW. B.
THIS BILL WOULD NOT REQUIRE THE
STATE TO START ACCEPTING VIRTUAL
CURRENCY IN FACT IF THIS BILL
WERE TO MOVE INDIVIDUAL AGENCIES
THAT EXPRESSED INTEREST IN
ACCEPTING PAYMENTS COULD CONDUCT
THEIR OWN STUDY. AND MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT IF THEY'RE
WILLING OR ABLE TO ACCEPT IT.
AND SEE. ANY BILL THAT DEALS
WITH CURRENCY SHOULD MAKE SURE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS ARE IN
PLACE THAT SAFEGUARDS AGAINST
MALICIOUS ACTORS AND THERE ARE
VIABLE SOLUTIONS FOR THOSE AS
WELL AS SOLUTIONS FOR USER
PRIVACY. MY HOPE IS THAT THIS
WOULD BE ABLE TO CONTINUE SO
THAT THOSE DETAILS AND
GUARDRAILS COULD BE FLESHED OUT
. I ALSO WANT TO ADD THAT THERE
ARE STATE LEVEL STUDIES
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW AS WELL AS
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER COMING FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE THAT ASKS FOR A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS. THE STUDY
AND PROVIDE GUIDANCE. IN THAT
REPORT IS SCHEDULED TO BE
FINISHED AND RELEASED IN
SEPTEMBER SO LOTS OF OUR EYES
ARE ON THIS ISSUE. AND SB TWELVE
SEVENTY FIVE WOULD JUST ALLOW A
LAUNCH PAD FOR WHEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS READY. WITH ME IN
SUPPORT TODAY IS ALLEY MEDINA
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
BLOCKCHAIN ADVOCACY COALITION
AND MICHELLE NEEDS FROM
BLOCKCHAIN LAW AND SOCIAL GOOD
CENTER- WITHOUT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I THINK I'M ALSO SUPPOSED TO
MENTION THAT. MY TWO WITNESSES
ARE IN THE GENERAL Q. RATHER-THAN THE DEDICATED LINE. AND SO
THEY MAY HAVE TO BE CALLED OUT.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
COM AUGER I WILL NOW MOVES ON TO
ANYONE WAITING. WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT- SO LET'S
MOVE THERE'S NOBODY IN THE
CHAMBERS LET'S MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR. AND IF SO YOU
CAN PRESS ONE ZERO WE CAN OPEN
YOUR LINE.
DISBARMENT HERE. ILLEGAL LINE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHELLE
NEEDS AND I AM A LAW PROFESSOR
AT GOLDEN GATE UNIVERSITY I AM
ALSO THE FOUNDING DIRECTOR OF
THE BLOCKCHAIN LOT FOR SOCIAL
GOOD CENTER AND I WAS A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA BLOCKCHAIN
WORKING GROUP IN TWENTY NINETEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY. OUT WE'RE
HERE BECAUSE BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THE CRYPTO CURRENCY IS
A NEW TECHNOLOGY THAT THE BILL
IS INTRIGUING BECAUSE IT RAISES
THE POSSIBILITY THAT CALIFORNIA
COULD BE INVOLVED WITH THE USE
OF CRYPTO CURRENCIES AS A WAY TO
FOSTER FINANCIAL INCLUSION. SO
WE WOULD ADVOCATE FOR A BALANCED
AND RESEARCH APPROACH TO THE
ISSUE A CRYPTOCURRENCY VIEWED BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AS
OUTLINED IN THE CALIFORNIA
BLOCKCHAIN WORKING GROUP REPORT
THAT WAS PUBLISHED. IN JULY OF
TWENTY TWENTY- YOU KNOW THAT'S
IN THE IN. FINDERS IN IN
NUMEROUS. AROUND THE WORLD FOCUS
ON FINANCIAL. AND WE NEED TO
DEVELOP A BETTER PATH TOWARDS
FINANCIAL INCLUSION IN
CALIFORNIA. WELL WHERE THERE ARE
SUCH HIGH NUMBERS OF UNBANKED
AND UNDERBANKED POPULATIONS
ESPECIALLY AMONG COMMUNITY AS A
COLOR. CURRENTLY IN A- COULD
PLAY A ROLE IN THIS EFFORT TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL SERVICES TO
TRADITIONALLY DISENFRANCHISED
POPULATION. AND GOVERNMENT
PAYMENTS AND RECEIPT OF PAYMENT
WOULD BE A STEP FORWARD. SO WITH
NEW TECHNOLOGY THERE ARE MANY
ISSUES TO BE CONSIDERED. FIRST
THE ISSUE OF PRIVACY AND
CYBERSECURITY ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE AVOID UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WHILE IT IS
ENSURING THAT INNOVATION AND
PUBLIC PROTECTION ARE WELL
BALANCED. WE ALSO SHOULD MAKE
SURE TO BE CAREFUL IN OUR
SELECTION OF A BLOCKCHAIN
APPLICATION TO RECEIVE AN
ADMINISTER CRYPTO PAYMENT.
BECAUSE IT MUST BE FLEXIBLE
ENOUGH TO ADAPT TO THE
FLUCTUATIONS. HAPPENING IN THIS
NEW TECHNOLOGY. LASTLY WE HOPE
THAT LED TO WOULD CONSIDER USING
AN APPLICATION THE FIFTY AND
WITH CALIFORNIA'S STATED VALUES
FROM THE BLOCKCHAIN WORKING
GROUP REPORT. THESE INCLUDE
ENVIRONMENTAL SUSTAINABILITY AND
ISSUES OF FAIRNESS AND EQUITY
WHEN SELECTING APPLICATIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT IN THE
LINE FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU HI CARE DRIVING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I AND I'M
GUESSING THAT YOU KNOW THE
DIRECTOR BLOCKCHAIN OUT OF THE
COALITION SPEAKING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO R. AND AT
TWELVE THIRTY AT THE TOP OF
FIVE. I COULD ABOUT WHAT
CRYPTOCURRENCY INDUSTRY TO LOOKS
LIKE AND HOW YEAH OVER A
THOUSAND VIRTUAL CURRENT THAT.
BE AN EASY PERCENT OF THEM ARE
SMALL. WELL YOU HAVE BEEN EIGHT.
WE HOW OF OUR MARKETS THE
COMPANY'S USUAL LACK OF REGULAR
CLEAR CAN HELP AND MARKET SHARE
DROP FROM PERCENT 210% IN MOSTAR
THREE WE HAVEN'T TWENTY OF THAT
WELCOME ARE SHARE THE TOTAL
ABOUT IN REPUBLIC BILL A YEAR
WHICH LAW THREE HUNDRED MILLION
MARKET SHARE HELP THINK WE'LL
YEAR- REGULATORY CLEAR IN MY
COMPANIES HAVE LEAVING STATES.
EX LIKELY AND SWITZERLAND.
ACTUALLY BIRECTIFIED BELL. I'M
AT HOPING FIVE PEOPLE CAN BUY
PREPAID HOPPING GRADING FEATURE
PERSONAL. STANDARD PARTY CLASS
OUT NOT AROUND FOR OVER A DECADE
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF THE
VIRTUAL CURRENCY TRANSACTIONS.
THERE'S ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ALONE ON A ONE POINT TWO FIVE
MILLION ON THE NEXT BLOCK. A LOT
OF PEOPLE USING THE TECHNOLOGY
ON BE JOAQUIN. THE FIRST STEP IN
OUR EVEN PEOPLE ACCESSIBILITY
HELP WHO ALREADY YOU
CRYPTOCURRENCY ARE STATED MANY
THE NOW ONE NICK CARTER READY
FRIEDMAN NAY. YOU CAN BE ON A
VEHICLE QUARTER RELATED SEARCHES
THE NUMBER OF COOKING EACH YEAR
. WHICH ARE HEAVILY UNDER UNDER
BANK. SAN FRANCISCO FINALLY HOW
THE MOST ACTIVE USERS WITH ANY
UNITED STATES. AND THAT MORNING
I PAID A BILL WITH THE AFRICAN
MCCARTY CARD EACH PERSON YOU
KEEP 3% C. THAT'S NOT UNUSUAL
THAT'S WHAT AROUND. THE ANY KIND
CARD CASH GOING TO HELP BREAKING
YOUR MARKET COULD. WE BE ABLE TO
BEAT THAT THE VERY THEIR OWN I
DIDN'T A COPY THAT WE HI ON HELP
. THEY'RE ABLE TO HIT PAPER
SERVICES USING KERR.
CALIFORNIA'S NATIONALLY ON MANY
ISSUES I CAME INTO YOUR
CHRONOLOGICAL BRINGING UP THE-
POSTER ON THE PARTICULAR ISSUE
AND I URGE YOU TO VOTE IN FAVOR.
OF THE STOP THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PLEASE PROCEED
MODERATOR. THANK YOU WE CAN
MEXICO TO LINE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING TERRY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KEVIN CHARMER
AND THE OTHER DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE DIGITAL CURRENCY TRADERS
ALLIANCE. THE NATION'S ONLY
DEDICATED CRYPTOCURRENCY
CONSUMER PROTECTION GROUP NUMBER
IN STOCK FOR TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND CURRENTLY NINE
FURTHERING Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MODERATE HAVING HEARD FROM
ALL THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS AND HEAR
FROM ANY OPPOSITION. I BELIEVE
WE HAVE BEEN TRIP- FOR THE
CALIFORNIA. STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE HERE IN THE CHAMBER TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION SIR PLEASE
BEGIN. GIVE ME A GET THE MIKE UP
TOP PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY MY NAME'S
BEEN TRIP BOTH THE OFFICES THE
CONTROLLER BETTY YEE CONTROLLER
YOU RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES SB
TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE WHICH ALLOWS
THE AGENCIES TO ACCEPT
CRYPTOCURRENCY IS A FORM OF
PAYMENT. AS CALIFORNIA'S CHIEF
FISCAL OFFICER CONTROL HE
BELIEVES IT WOULD BE FISCALLY
IRRESPONSIBLE THE STATE TO
VENTURE INTO THE CRYPTOCURRENCY
SPACE AT THIS TIME SEOS PRIMARY
CONCERN CENTERS ON OUR OFFICES
CONSTITUTIONAL RESPONSIBILITY TO
PRODUCE TIMELY AND ACCURATE YEAR
END FINANCIAL REPORTS IN BOTH
THE BUDGETARY LEGAL BASIS IN A
FORMAT CONSISTENT WITH GENERALLY
ACCEPTED ACCOUNTING PRINCIPLES.
CALIFORNIA WAS ELEVEN MONTHLY
PUBLISHING THE FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
YOU KNOW COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL
REPORT. WHICH DID NOT INCLUDE A
CLEAN AUDIT IN THE SHOULD NOT BE
REPEATED. PERSONALLY YEAR END
REPORTING FOR FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS CURRENTLY
TRACKING WORSE THAN LAST YEAR
SIXTEEN AGENCIES AND A HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE FUNDS STILL
DELINQUENT IN REPORTING THEIR
BUDGETARY LEGAL FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS. WELL AS HE WAS
WORKING WITH THESE DEPARTMENTS
INTRODUCING DIGITAL CURRENCIES A
METHOD OF PAYMENT FOR GOVERNMENT
SERVICES BILL TIME AND NOT
PRUDENT. GIVEN THE NEWNESS OF
CRYPTO CURRENCIES PREVAILING
ACCOUNTING PRINCIPLES WERE
ESTABLISHED A TIME TO DIGITAL
CURRENCIES WERE NOT YET
CONTEMPLATED. CALIFORNIA HAVE
WOULD HAVE CRYPTO CURRENCIES ON
ITS LEDGER STATE AGENCIES WOULD
BE LEFT WITHOUT ACCOUNTING
GUIDANCE IT WOULD NEED TO APPLY
ARCANE CAL ACCOUNTING STANDARDS
TO NEW TECHNOLOGY. MOREOVER
BECAUSE OF THE EXTREME
FLUCTUATIONS IN CRYPTOCURRENCY
VALUE THERE ON DOWN TO BE
DISCREPANCIES INHERENT WITH
RECONCILIATIONS MEETING THE
FINANCIAL REPORTS FOR THE SCO.
FOR FEAR FOR YEAR END FINANCIAL
PARTS. IF RESPONSIBLY REGULATED
FOR CONSUMERS PROTECTIONS
CALIFORNIA MAIN BRACE THE USE OF
CRYPTOCURRENCY HOWEVER IT MUST
BE DONE IN A FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE MANNER TO ENSURE
ABILITY TO ACCURATELY MEASURE
AND ACCOUNT FOR PERFORMANCE.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TESTIFIED HAVE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OF
THE CHAMBER- MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE PROP INDIVIDUALS WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE.
THANK YOU INTO A OPPOSE SB
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE YOU CAN PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO. AND GIVE US
JUST A MOMENT HERE.
AND WE GO TO LINE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL AND WE
LOOK FOR TO THINK ANY CHANGES
ARE MADE THE BILL BUT WE- WERE.
AND CURRENTLY NONE FURTHER IN Q.
OKAY THANK YOU TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK
TO OUR MEMBERS. ANYBODY WISHING
TO. YES THIS CENTER BACKER. YES
A TWENTIETH OF PERSONAL THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER WORK ON THIS
AT MEASURE- AND- DO YOU TAKE THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE- COMMENTS
IS SERIOUSLY I DID YOU WANT TO
ASK YOU KNOW IF YOU'D BE WILLING
TO DESERT AT POSSIBLE DOING SOME
KIND OF PILOT. OR SOMETHING
THAT- MIGHT ALLOW TO TEST THIS
OUT WITHOUT- REQUIRED A LOT OF
WORK ON A LARGER SCALE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- ABSOLUTELY
INTERESTED IN. A PILOT-
INTERESTED IN ENGAGING WITH
DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO FIGURE OUT
WHICH ONES ARE MOST INTERESTED
IN VENTURING INTO THIS SPACE. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE DEALS
MOSTLY WITH PAYROLL AND SO THIS
ISN'T NECESSARILY ANYTHING THAT
WOULD COME TO THAT PARTICULAR
OFFICE AND I KNOW THERE BEEN
MANY DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
VOLATILITY AND FLUCTUATION SO
ALSO INTERESTED IN PRESENTING
MORE GUARD RAILS. SO THAT THE
STATE DOESN'T HAVE TO
NECESSARILY ACCEPT THE
CRYPTOCURRENCY AND THAT FORM BUT
COULD ACCEPT IT AS IT IS
CONVERTED INTO CASH. WHICH WILL
STOP THE VOLATILITY IN ISSUES
AND CONCERNS AROUND FLUCTUATION-
SO THE SHORT ANSWER AGAINST THE
LONG ANSWER IS YES. THANK YOU
ARE BE WILLING TO HELP SUPPORT
IN THE INTEREST OF CONTINUED ON
THOSE DISCUSSIONS. SENATOR
GLAZERS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND I ALSO ENJOYED THANKING THE
AUTHOR FOR ADVANCING THIS
DISCUSSION BECAUSE IT'S AN
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION WE SEE- HOW
NEW INNOVATIONS AND PAYMENT
SYSTEMS AND- MONEY ARE HAPPENING
AROUND THE GLOBE- THE CONTROLLER
WAS VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT THE
PROBLEMS THAT SHE SAW WITH- WITH
ALLOWING THIS IN OUR STATE IN
TERMS OF THE FINANCIAL REPORTS
THAT. THAT OFFICE IS REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE AND THE PROBLEMS THAT
SHE'S HAD- JUST IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS OF SOLVING THE AUTHOR
COULD SPEAK TO THAT ISSUE WITH
THE FINANCIAL REPORTS THAT COULD
BE IN JEOPARDY- WITHOUT EITHER
OF YOU KNOW THE CARE THAT I KNOW
WE ALL WOULD WANT INDICT VANCE
IN THIS TYPE OF A PROGRAM AND
HAD A SECOND FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS
WELL MISTER CHAIRMAN. AND THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION- THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT THIS IS NOT
HAPPENING TODAY AND IT WOULDN'T
HAPPEN TOMORROW AND I THINK MANY
OF- THE STATEMENTS AND COMMENTS
BOTH IN THE LETTER OF OPPOSITION
IN THE STATEMENTS TODAY TALK
ABOUT THE REPORTS THAT THE BACK
LOGGED ON NOW MY EXPECTATION AND
EVEN THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT THIS
ISN'T ANYTHING THAT WOULD HAPPEN
IMMEDIATELY I ALSO BELIEVE AS I
SIT IN CHAIR BUDGET SUB THAT
THEY'RE INTERESTED IN A BUDGET
INCREASE TO HELP THEM WITH THIS
KIND OF BACKLOG AND- I THINK
THAT'S ALSO VERY IMPORTANT- IT
DOES. AND THIS YOU KNOW MOVING
SOMETHING FORWARD ALLOWS FOR
THESE KINDS OF QUESTIONS TO BE
RAISED AND TO BE TACKLED. I'M
USING- THE REPORTS THAT HAVE
COME OUT OF THE BLOCKCHAIN
WORKING GROUP USING HOPEFULLY
THE STUDY THAT WILL COME FROM
THE FBI- IN A FINANCIAL
PROTECTION AND INNOVATION AND
HOPEFULLY EVEN USING THE
GUIDANCE THAT WOULD COME FROM-
THE WHITE HOUSE. THE SECOND
QUESTION WAS THERE AT THE
ANALYSIS AND THANK YOU TO THE
STAFF FOR WRITING A TERRIFIC
ANALYSIS ON THE BILL- RAISES THE
AYE CONCERNED IT INDICATES AT
LEAST THAT IT THIS ONE STATE HAD
ADOPTED THIS OHIO- AND THEN-
QUICKLY REVERSED COURSE. ARE YOU
AWARE OF ANY OTHER STATE THAT'S
ALLOWING THIS TYPE OF. ACTION TO
TAKE PLACE YES SO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE- THE
ISSUE WITH THE OHIO IT REVERSED
COURSE BECAUSE THERE WAS THAT A
CHANGE- IN THE PERSON IN THE
POSITION YOU HAVE THE AUTHORITY-
TO MOVE THAT KIND OF FORWARD
THAT- THIS ISSUE FORWARD AT. A
PARTY CHANGE AS WELL AS AN
IDEOLOGICAL CHANGE- BUT THERE AS
I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING THEIR
THIRTY SEVEN STATES THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN THIS WYOMING. NEW
YORK. ARIZONA OKLAHOMA COLORADO-
MANY OF THEM ARE EITHER.
ALLOWING YOU TO ACTUALLY PAY
YOUR TAXES WHAT DID VIRTUAL
CURRENCY ALLOWING YOU TO
PURCHASE A LOTTERY TICKETS
ALLOWING YOU TO PAY FOR
REGISTRATION FEES- YOU KNOW
ALLOWING YOU TO RECORD YOUR
INVESTMENTS AND SO THERE ARE
DOZENS OF- STATES. THAT HAVE
INTRODUCED- LAST YEAR AND THIS
YEAR THIS KIND OF LEGISLATION.
IN MY IN MY- MY TIME- I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT- NOT ALWAYS LIKE
CALIFORNIA TO BE AND- THE
INNOVATION STATE AND TO- IT'LL
BE A LEADER AND NEW TECHNOLOGIES
. BUT I REMAIN WORRIED AND
CONCERNED THAT- THAT WE MAY BE
GOING A LITTLE TOO FAST AND- I
WOULD LIKE TO. SEE A LITTLE BIT
MORE STUDY DONE AND MORE-
CALIBRATED. SMALL BABY STEPS
INTO THE SPACE- VERSUS THE
BROADER- AUTHORIZATION THAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED IN THE BILL
AND SO I AND- I AM IN A LAYOFF
THE BILL TODAY AND HOPE THAT- IF
THE BILL DOES MOVE FORWARD IT-
IT WEEK. IT CAN BE NARROWED TO A
PLACE OF A MORE THOUGHTFUL STUDY
AND CARE. ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO ADDRESS THE BODY ON THIS.
OKAY CENTER CAMARGO I BELIEVE
THE BILL'S PREMATURE IT COULD
LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS FOR
BOTH THE STATE AND THOSE SEEKING
TO USE THIS TYPE OF CURRENCY WE
MUST MAKE SURE THE APPROPRIATE
SAFEGUARDS ARE IN PLACE AND
ENSURE THAT CUSTOMERS ARE
INFORMATION IS WELL PROTECTED
YOU HAVE BEEN DOLLARS YOURSELF
ABOUT THE STATE STUDY THAT'S
COMING THE FEDERAL STUDY THIS
COMING- I BELIEVE WE SHOULD WAIT
AND SEE WHAT THOSE STUDIES.
PRODUCED BEFORE WE MOVE DOWN
THAT ROAD WAS INTERESTING
BECAUSE I WAS- ON THE PHONE WITH
SENATOR COM AUGER THIS MORNING
PRIOR TO THAT THE TODAY SHOW
REPORTED THIS MORNING THE CRYPTO
CURRENCY IS THE SECOND LEADING
FRAUDULENT AREA IN FINANCE IN
THE COUNTRY TODAY. THAT IS VERY
CONCERNING TO ME IS WILL WELL I
HOPE THAT YOU WOULD AGREE TO A
WORKING GROUP TO STUDY THIS
ISSUE AND ALLOW MORE TIME TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE YOU'RE OPEN TO
THAT SUGGESTION SO ODD
UNFORTUNATELY I CANNOT SUPPORT
THE BILL AS IS SENATOR COM AUGER
WHICH I DO CLOSE. YES THANK. YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I AM.
WHOLEHEARTEDLY AGREE AND I'M
OPEN TO A DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
AS I MENTIONED IN MY OPENING IT
THIS IS A PERMISSIVE BILL AND SO
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT OR
MANDATE. THAT ALL AGENCIES HAVE
TO START IMMEDIATELY ACCEPTING
DIGITAL CURRENCY AS PAYMENT-
THERE IS A BIG DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN INVESTING IN DIGITAL
CURRENCY WHICH I THINK WHERE
MOST OF THE DISCUSSION LINES.
AND THEN ACTUALLY USING DIGITAL
CURRENCY TO PAY FOR SOMETHING-
THERE'S ALSO A HUGE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN ACCEPTING DIGITAL
CURRENCY IN ITS FORM RIGHT AND
IT'S DIGITAL FORM. AS OPPOSED TO
WORKING WITH THIRD PARTY VENDORS
TO CONVERT IT INTO CASH WE
ACTUALLY THERE IS A AS A BANK
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
THAT ACCEPTS DIGITAL CURRENCY
AND SO THESE THINGS ARE
HAPPENING. IN CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE AND
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS AS I
MENTIONED TO CREATE A LAUNCHING
PAD FOR THE STATE TO BEGIN TO.
INCREMENTALLY OR NOT MOVE INTO
THIS SPACE AS WELL I WANT TO
ALSO ADD THAT THE UNITED STATES
IS TIED FOR TENTH PLACE IN THE
WORLD IN TERMS OF HOW MANY OF
OUR CITIZENS ARE RESIDENTS. OWN
AND USE DIGITAL CURRENCY- THE
PEOPLE BEEN TALKING ABOUT RISK
YOU KNOW THE INTERNET IS RISKY
PEOPLE WERE SCARED ABOUT
INVESTING IN INTERNET STOCKS IN
THE NINETIES AND THEN LOOK WHAT
HAPPENED- AND I'M CERTAINLY NOT
SUGGESTING. THAT WE DON'T TAKE
ANY OF THOSE THINGS INTO
CONSIDERATION IN FACT WHAT I'M
SUGGESTING IS WHY DON'T WE USE
THE RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
REPORT THAT ARE IN PROCESS NOW
TO HELP GUIDE HOW WE CONTINUE TO
DEVELOP GUARD RAILS. AND YET
ALLOW FOR THE FLEXIBILITY THAT
CAN ENCOURAGE THOUSANDS HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS PERHAPS MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE DIGITAL
CURRENCY AND WOULD LIKE THAT TO
PAY FOR A STATE PROVISION. IN A
WAY THAT IS SAFE IN A WAY THAT
IS SECURE AND IN A WAY THAT DOES
NOT EEP BILL. PUSH THE
LIABILITY OF VOLATILITY ON TO
THE STATE THERE ARE SO MANY
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE OUT THERE
AND THIS BILL IS JUST ASKING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BE PART
OF DISCUSSING- THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS I RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A
NO VOTE COMING FROM THE CHAIR
AND IF THIS WERE TO FAIL I AM
WOULD CERTAINLY ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION SO THAT WE CAN
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION. IN THIS HOUSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU CENTER CALM WATER- WE HAVE A
MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR BACKER. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS COMMITTEE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. NO
GUARDINO NIELSEN. NIELSEN ALLEN
ARCHULETA. BAKER BAKER I BORDERS
ORDERS NO BRADFORD GLAZER.
WESTELL JONES. KAMLAGER KAMLAGER
HI MELENDEZ PORTANTINO. RUBIO
WILK THAT'S GOT ONE TWO THREE
TURN ON CALL THE BILL IS ON CALL
THANK YOU TO REQUIREMENTS ARE
TWO TO THREE OKAY WITH TWO VOTES
UP THE BILLS ON CALL. OKAY YOU
WANT TO GO BACK THROUGH THE
THAT'S WHAT THE EVERYTHING YES
PLEASE. YOU ARE A ON SECOND.
OKAY WELL IF THE CALLS WILL
START WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
IN THE CONSENT CALENDAR HI THIS
IS ON THE CAN THANK OUR MEMBERS
ABSENT MEMBERS NO FAN. CHAU
DAHLE SAID HI BRADFORD GLAZER
GLAZER HI WESO JONES. KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I WILK OKAY TERMINUS ON
CALL. OKAY WILL NOW MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B. NINETY TWO
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE S.
B. A. NINETY TWO ABSENT MEMBERS
NELSON. NIELSEN AND ALTHOUGH TO
ASK ALLEN. BORDERS BRADFORD
WESTELL JONES KAMLAGER KAMLAGER
I MELENDEZ WILK. IT WILL MOVE
THE FILE ITEM OF NUMBER THREE SB
NINE NINE THREE ABSENT MEMBERS
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE ALLEN
BRADFORD WESO JONES KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER AYE PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE WILK ON COURT.
THOSE ON CALL- THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR S. B. TEN OH ONE-
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB
TENS OR ONE ABSENT MEMBERS
NIELSEN. ALLEN ALLEN HI BRADFORD
WEST SO JONES. KAMLAGER KAMLAGER
AYE PORTANTINO PORTANTINO AYE
WILK. COME FACCIO- THE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE S. B. CHANNEL FOUR
THAT GOT PULLED THAT THAT BILL
GOT PULLED WELL THAT'S WHAT
CURRENT THANK YOU. SO MOVE- TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX. SB ELEVEN
FORTY FOUR. YES FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB ELEVEN FORTY FOUR- ABSENT
MEMBERS NIELSEN. ALLEN ALLEN HI
GORGEOUS. BRADFORD WESTELL
WESTELL I JONES. KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER AYE PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO AYE WILK ON CALL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
TWELVE OH THREE. FOLLOW NUMBER
SEVEN SB TWELVE OF THREE ABSENT
MEMBERS NIELSEN. NELSON NO ALLEN
. AYE ALLEN AYE GORGEOUS.
BRADFORD WESTELL WESTELL HI
JONES KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HI
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I WILL.
THAT'S OUR CULTURE FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT S. B. TWELVE FIFTY
ONE. S. B. R. BAL HARBOUR EIGHT
SB TWELVE FIFTY ONE ABSENT
MEMBERS NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
BRADFORD GLAZER GLAZER AYE WESO. WESO NO JONES. KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER AYE PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE WILK. THAT'S ON
CULTURE FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE S.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE. YOU WANT
TO GO TO SEVEN COULD YOU GO BACK
NUMBER EIGHT YEAH LET'S MOVE
BACK TO FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
TWELVE FIFTY ONE- LET'S REOPEN
THE ROLE AND DO THAT OVER PLEASE
YET THAT'S A REAL IN THE REFER
ABSENT MEMBERS AND CENTER BLESS
ALL COME BACK TO YOU- BRADFORD.
JONES. WELL CANCER WAS SO YOU
WANT TO CHANGE ABOUT. FROM WESO
FROM NO TO HI ONCOGENIC K. THAT
WILL MOVE TO- FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE
SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE SB TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE DOT SHARE VOTING NO
BY SERMON VOTING NO ALLEN.
ARCHULETA BRADFORD LASER WEST OF. WESTOVER NO JONES. MELENDEZ
PORTANTINO RUBIO WILK THAT'S TWO
TO THREE TO FOUR CHAIRMAN ON
CALL. THAT WILL MOVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER. ELEVEN SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THIS IS FILE I'M
ELEVEN SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN. ALLEN
ALLEN HI GORGEOUS BORDERS NO
BRADFORD. WESO WESSEL HI JONES.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO AYE WILK
ON CULTURE. NO TEN NO ON S. B.
THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN. A GERMAN
UP SOME CALLS OKAY WILL NOW MOVE
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE S. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY MEMBER
TWELVE SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO ALLEN. ALLEN I
BORDERS BORDERS FIVE BRADFORD.
WESTELL WESTELL I JONES.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO AYE WILK
ON TOP. NO NOT KAMLAGER ON SB
FORTY SEVENTY EIGHT. HI. OKAY WE
STILL HAVE DO WE KNOW WHAT'S
GOING ON A PUBLIC SAFETY RIGHT
NOW WE STILL HAVE A FEW MEMBERS
THERE.
OKAY. SO YES WE HAVE EVERYBODY
HERE. RIGHT SO WE'RE GONNA OPEN
A ONE MORE AND THEN WE'RE GONNA
DURING THE MEETING. LET ME
DOUBLE CHECK REAL QUICK. NIELSEN
ALLEN WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE
CONSENT- CALENDAR. YEAH THEY
WERE GOOD VERY SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SO THIS IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS
BRADFORD. WEST OF. WESO HI JONES
JONES FIVE WILK THAT HAS.
THIRTEEN ZERO CHAIRMAN THAT'S
OUT. THANK YOU WILL MVE TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE S. B. NINE EIGHT
TWO EXCUSE ME SECTOR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE- ONE SB EIGHT NINETY TWO
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN. NOT
VOTING ALLEN. FORGERS BRADFORD
WESO. OUR IT'S. SEVEN TWO ZERO.
WESO HI JONES. NUMBER EIGHT
MELENDEZ WILK. THAT'S EIGHTY
ZERO CHAIRMAN THE BILL IS OUT.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE S. B. NINE
NINE THREE. FILE I'M NUMBER
THREE SB NINE NINE THREE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN. BRADFORD WESTELL
WESO I'D JONES. GEN WELCOME.
THAT'S ELEVEN TO THEIR
ADJOURNMENT A BILL IS OUT. FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR S. B. TEN- ONE
. FOLLOWING OR FOR SB TEN A ONE
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN. BRADFORD
SO WESO HI JONES. WILK. THAT'S
ELEVEN DESERVE TERMINA BILLS OUT
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX WHAT THE
BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX. WELL I'M NUMBER SIX SB
ELEVEN FORTY FOUR- ABSENT
MEMBERS NELSON. FORGERS BRADFORD
. WEST UP OUTSIDE I WAS A- JONES
. JONES NO WILK. THAT'S TEN TO
ONE SHERMAN THE BILL AS I WAS.
THE BILL IS OUT IN ONE- NOW
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN. WELL I'M NUMBER
SEVEN SB TWELVE OH THREE ABSENT
MEMBERS GORGEOUS. BRADFORD JONES
. JONES NO WILK. THAT'S NINETY
THREE CHAIRMAN THE BILL IS OUT.
FILE NINETY THREE THAT BILL IS
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT SB
TWELVE FIFTY ONE. ABSENT MEMBERS
BRADFORD JONES JONES NO WILK.
THAT'S NINETY FOUR CHAIRMAN OF
BILL IS OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE SB TWELVE SEVENTY FIVE
CHAIRMAN VOTING NO VICE CHAIRMAN
VOTING NO ALLEN OR TO LET- AT
THE FOLLOWING NUMBER TWELVE
TWENTY FIVE KAMLAGER. OKAY ALLEN
. ARCHULETA. BRADFORD GLAZER
JONES JONES NO MELENDEZ
PORTANTINO RUBIO WELCOME SHERMAN
THAT HAS TWO TO FIVE THAT
MEASURE FAILS. THAT MEASURE
FAILS TO FIVE YOU WANNA GRANT
RECONSIDERATION. YES I WOULD BE
HAPPY TO GRANDKIDS
RECONSIDERATION BUT- WILL NOW
MOVE THE FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY SEVEN FILE
I'M ELEVEN SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. ABSENT MEMBERS. OFFERED
JONES. JONES I WILK. TWENTY
THREE CHAIRMAN OF THOSE OUT
TWENTY THREE THE BILLS OUT FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT THIS IS FILE A
MEMBER TWELVE SB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT ABSENT MEMBERS
BRADFORD. JONES. WILK. AT ELEVEN
TO ONE SHERMAN A BILL IS OUT OF
THE ONE THAT'S OUT- SENATOR
ALLEN IS BACK IN THE CHAMBERS.
WE CAN'T GO BACK. I DON'T THINK
I CLOSED OUT THE ONES THAT HE
DIDN'T VOTE ON. ON YOU WANNA
YEAH I YOU CAME ALL THE WAY BACK
FOR THIS I DID THE STAFF TO BE
ABLE TO VOTE. OKAY- SO AFTER I
WHEN YOU ARE NOT HONEST. FILE
ITEM IT WILL OPEN UP A LOT OF
NUMBER ONE. PLEASE THE FILING OF
ONE SB EIGHT NINETY TWO ABSENT
MEMBERS. NIELSEN ALLEN. ALLEN I
BORDERS BRADFORD. JONES MELENDEZ
WILK SO THAT'S NINETY ZERO
TRIMMING YOU WANNA CLOSE AT NINE
ZERO THAT'S OUT. AND THEN CENTER
ALIGN YOU'RE ALSO NOT ON FILE
ITEM OR THREE PLEASE THE
FOLLOWING NUMBER THREE SB NINE
NINE THREE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN
. ALLEN HI BRADFORD. JONES
WELCOME. THAT'S TWELVE DESERT
SHERMAN YOU WANT CLOSER CLOSE IT
REPORTER NOT. I THINK THAT'S IT
. HE'S GOT ONE YEAH THAT'S RIGHT
. OKAY. I APPRECIATE ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU FOR
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON. HEALTH ORGANIZATION. IS A
JERK.